due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor and as a result of the
covet 19 pandemic and in accordance with
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee
meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice of this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa
91-a the right to know law
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
three six 271-3600-271-3600 or email hcs
at leg leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
we do have one staff member who is
monitoring the meeting that's jennifer
iv our committee researcher
please note that all votes that would be
taken during this meeting if any would
be done by roll call vote we do not
intend to exec any bills today as
several committee members are
unavailable to attend
we're going to start the meeting by
taking roll call attendance
each member should state their presence
also state whether there's anyone in the
room with you during the meeting which
is required under the right to know law
and
our clerk
is testifying on another bill and is not
here immediately
so i'm going to call upon our vice chair
representative mclean to take the role
thank you mr chair um
chairman gordon
i am here i'm in the legislative office
building
with other committee members
i'm representative mclean i'm here and
i'm in the lob with the chair
representative sylvia
i am
at home in belmont
and uh enjoying the view from here
okay the clerk will be along in a bit uh
representative alexander
representative rice
representative silver
representative green
yes i'm here in my home in hudson my
wife is coming and going here and there
today
representative kelly
i'm here in temple with the dog and
there are family members in the house
but nowhere near me
representative tausch
representative
representative trottier
[Music]
representative smith
ronaldo smith
representative burst
uh good morning i am in west milan in my
home uh by myself
good morning
representative
horrigan
i am i am here in durham
by myself
representative de lorenzo
representative lorenzo
she was here she was i'll come back to
her
uh
representative chase
rollinsford in my home by myself
representative kenny
good morning i'm here um in durham
roommates are in the apartment but they
are not in the room but they may be
throughout the day thank you thank you
representative langley
representative macbeth
good morning i'm here in my portsmouth
office
alone
thank you
you're welcome good morning
uh representative page
good morning i'm in exeter with kids in
the house
thank you good morning
representative simpson
hello i'm in exeter i am alone but my
spouse and children may be through at
some point
representative dilorenzo
okay
i don't i don't know for sure but she
and reverend whelper may be uh
testifying at the same hearing and i'm
actually hopping off at 9 15 to attend
that one too but i'll be back we'll all
be back as soon as we can i'm sure
all right thank you
thank everyone uh we're here this
morning to hear a senate bill this is
senate bill 134.
senate bill 134 has
is an omnibus bill it has 11 different
parts
and our our plan today is to
call upon the primary sponsor first of
the omnibus bill itself call upon the
other senators who may have sponsored
portions of that bill
and uh
and then we will take testimony from the
rest of the people
i note that there are 45 people who have
signed up
in support of the bill
53 people who have signed up in
opposition to the bill
two people who have signed up who
indicate that they're neutral
and 27 people have signed up to testify
today
what we uh
most of the people who have signed up to
testify indicate that they plan to
testify for short periods of time
at least five minutes or short or there
are a couple of people who signed up to
speak
for longer than that but i think what
we'll do is try to hold everybody to
speak
for no longer than
five minutes at the most and uh will
time people to make sure that they can
stay within that time frame
we will
i think as we did with our
omnibus bill last week is
we're not going to go
section by section i'm not sure that
that's the most fair way to do it
otherwise you have people in the last
section waiting two or three hours to
testify
what we're going to do is we're going to
go through and we'll call upon those
people who have pre-registered to speak
and just ask them to identify what
portion or portions of the bill that
they want to speak to
before they give their testimony
and with that we will begin this morning
by calling upon the prime sponsor of the
bill and that is senator sharon carson
uh
could i ask a question yes
uh i just wanted to alert you and i
think you already know
that uh there's an amendment that i have
that i would at the appropriate time
like the opportunity simply to introduce
to the committee and and and have it as
part of the uh
proceeding
uh if i can ask our is it your intention
to add that to uh one section of the
bill
uh yes you would go on to part five of
the bill
and i i mentioned it because i think
some of the people attending may want to
speak to that amendment
uh
my
uh okay
and i i think the same thing as i just
got from uh from ols an amendment which
i think i might add to part seven of the
bill so i probably will address it when
we get to part sub
and if you wanted to address it when we
get
uh it when somebody testify when we
when somebody testifies to part seven i
will also address that if somebody
speaks to part five if you would address
it at the time i think that's probably a
good idea
thank you
okay and again i'll call upon senator
carson
good morning mr chairman and good
morning members of the house judiciary
committee for the record my name is
sharon carson and i have the pleasure of
representing senate district 14
comprising the towns of londonderry
hudson and auburn and i have this
morning for your consideration an
omnibus bill
which seeks to
which is really relative to civil
actions and criminal liability um the uh
the chair is correct there are
11 different parts to this bill these
again were all separate bills that were
filed
but we combined them just because of
time constraints
um so mr chairman um would you like to
me to go through
the uh parts of the bill that i um have
filed
well uh
to to the to the extent that you're the
primary sponsor and uh
yeah i think
uh
at least with regard to the bill we
heard last week
there was at least one portion of the
bill that nobody spoke to
after you spoke
so you might want to at least
mention each part as you go through to
introduce the bill
okay that's fine mr chairman um i do
have a time constraint um i do have
another omnibus bill that i have to
introduce into another committee as well
um so i will try to get through this as
quickly as possible
um and again thank you very much uh
for taking up this bill today the first
section of the bill
seeks to prohibit
certain uses of labor uh excuse me laser
pointing devices and mr chairman i do
have a
an amendment that i have had drawn up
that makes some additional corrections
to this bill um at the conclusion of the
hearing i will
have my
aides
email you that amendment so you can have
it for your deliberations um and i'm
sure that's
someone will be here to speak to that at
the appropriate time
um
let's see um
i'm looking for all my testimony here
um this bill was is really in response
to a bill that was uh
that was signed into law in 2016
which prohibited the shining of laser
pointers at airplanes law enforcement
officers law enforcement vehicles
persons
occupied vehicles and other structures
but it also included some limited
exceptions which had the unintentional
effect of making even some everyday uses
of lasers illegal such as vehicle
sensors golf range finders hunting range
finders and things of that nature
it also prohibited some research
activities that aerospace and defense
technology companies conduct with lasers
and
laser systems
and so really
the this particular part of the bill is
an attempt to clarify those lawful uses
of lasers while ensuring malicious
malicious use of lasers repeat retain
remain
prohibited
um
the second part of the bill
um is the result a revised uniform law
on ontario acts and the uniform real
property electronic recording acts
this
was a bill that came through last year
but
uh was i believe part of an omnibus bill
that died
and 28 states have notified their notary
laws to allow for this practice
and since we've been under the covid19
pandemic restraints
many notaries have moved to remote means
under executive order 11.
the governor did mention that some of
the executive orders should be reviewed
regarding putting them into statute
and a group of stakeholders worked over
the summer on this language including
the mortgage brokers and bankers
association the new hampshire bankers
association the new hampshire credit
union the new hampshire realtors the
register of deeds and title companies
the secretary of state also provided
input on this section
section three is incarceration under a
second under a suspended sentence
this will allow people to apply for a
suspended sentence earlier
and uh the committee did have an
amendment
on this
um part four is relative to
civil liability for damages to highways
mr chairman there is going to be an
amendment coming forward it's being
prepared uh today it should have been
here but unfortunately we did not
receive it enough time
um the department of
uh the department of transportation has
asked for this um
for this excuse me i'm on the wrong one
no no i'm right okay um
they've asked for this amendment for
additional clarifications
um
section uh this really was this part of
the bill section four
was filed uh at the request of the dark
department to assist them in collecting
monies owed to the state when people
have caused damage to the highways
uh part five concerns uh
is uh procedures for structured
settlements we were asked to file this
because new hampshire is the only state
that has not updated their structured
settlement laws
this legislation will bring new
hampshire into line with other states
there were a number of stakeholders that
have been working on this language um
and at the time of our public hearing
they did have an amendment which we did
adopt
um and
uh that is my testimony on that
particular uh part of the bill
part six is establishing the new
hampshire collaborative law act
um this bill was part of an omnibus bill
that was vetoed last year
and i'm looking to see where the
testimony was on that so i can give you
a little bit
more information
um i just have so many different pieces
of paper here
um let's see
um
okay that's structured settlements
okay
this um
really collaborative practice is a
privately contracted based business a
process of alternative dispute
resolution
in new hampshire collaborative law
practices uses a team approach with two
attorneys to represent the parties
a neutral facility coach facilitator and
a financial professional
this practice is primarily used in the
area of family law
currently prior to entering into the
process parties and professionals sign a
participation agreement that sets forth
the expectations and the parameters of
the process
the passage of this legislation will
standardize the contents of the
participation agreement and process
there are occasions where the
collaborative process is not successful
and in those instances the parties will
resort to litigation this act will
ensure the confidentiality of the
process by limiting the ability to enter
into evidence information that was
gleaned during the process
much like the mediation process ensuring
the confidentiality allows individuals
to look at options without being afraid
that they might come back to bite them
in the litigation process
this is based on a uniform collaboration
law act that is suited to new hampshire
and again there are 19 states that have
passed similar legislation and five
where it is pending
the next section is uh concerns program
administration
distribution upon intestacy and the
powers of the attorney and adopting
uniform disclaimer of property interests
act
section the next section which i believe
is section eight
uh school employee and school volunteer
criminal background
um criminal history background checks
and seeks to establish a committee to
study the department of education
oversight of criminal background history
checks for private schools
section 9 is making an appropriation
funding mental health
intervention training programs
of section 10
concerns employer access
to vehicle records
um and mr chairman i do have an
amendment which again i will be
forwarding to you
as soon as i can
uh we can get as soon as i'm finished
here today
this section of the bill was filed at
the request of the department of
transportation
and they've seen a significant rise in
the number of delivery drivers on our
roadways
as you can imagine i think we've all
seen amazon trucks going through our
neighborhood
and
this is even more as a result of the
covet 19 pandemic with more goods and
services being delivered to homes and
businesses
this section would streamline the
process for employers to obtain motor
vehicle and license records from the
department of motor vehicles to allow
the release of electronic records which
will ultimately help protect public
safety
virtually all other states allow
electronic employer driving record and
license status checks
this bill would put new hampshire in
line with what is currently practiced
across the country
importantly these bills are already
disclosed to employers these records
excuse me are already disclosed to
employers on an individual basis under
new hampshire law
this bill would merely change the manner
in which the records can be released to
allow them into electronic
form
it will help facilitate employers
and the dmv to conduct motor vehicle
record checks more efficiently
when data on driving driver records and
license status is made available it
allows employers to identify high-risk
drivers
enforce company policies and make
well-educated driving decisions
consumer privacy protections currently
exist under federal law
and state law and will not be impacted
by this bill
for example the employee must consent
before the records are released
seven part seven
section seven there are others here to
testify that can answer the questions
um
and in the end this will streamline
current practice and help prevent unsafe
drivers from jeopardizing the safety of
our public roads roadways
mr chairman i'd like to offer a
correction this bill was not filed at
the at the request of the department of
transportation um i thought it was but
it's not
and finally uh section 12 which is the
authorization to grow industrial hemp
this was a bill that passed senate last
year was in an omnibus bill
and that omnibus bill was vetoed and it
simply will allow um
the growth people to grow
um industrial hemp but under certain
circumstances
this legislation came about because
there were companies that were looking
to relocate to new hampshire
and wanted to do
some business concerning industrial hemp
and because of our current laws they
were not allowed to do so
so i will at this point conclude my
testimony and i will thank you all very
much for your time this morning i'm sure
that there are
uh i heard you say 27 people that would
that wish to testify
um and i'm sure that they can answer
your very
uh good and very uh probative questions
much better than i could
thank you
is there anyone that does have a
question for senator carson
c none senator thank you for your
testimony today thank you thank you mr
chairman and we will get those
amendments out to you as soon as we can
thank you thank you and senator whitley
you can find her there
good morning thank you mr chair and good
morning members of the committee for the
record my name is becky whitley and i'm
honored to serve new hampshire senate
district 15 which includes the wonderful
communities of concord penacook henniker
hopkinton and warner so if i may i'd
like to speak to sections three
and seven
so speaking first to part three this is
relative to incarceration under
suspended sentence this is a bill that
actually passed the house last year in
the senate judiciary committee uh as
senator carson
indicated we did work with the
department of corrections and
other stakeholders to come up with a
compromise position
so the language that you see
in this version of the bill
that would simply allow folks to apply
for a suspended sentence within 12
months of serving two-thirds of the
minimum sentence that is the compromised
language the the previous
uh
policy that had passed the house was 18
months so i just wanted to point that
out and i'm very grateful to the
stakeholders that worked on that
compromise and brought it to the senate
judiciary committee
so the other uh part i would like to
speak to is part seven this is relative
to probate administration um and so
forth it has a lot in there i will say
this part of the bill actually combines
two bills from last session that also
had a cove of death like so many uh
bills did but just generally part seven
of this bill expands the waiver of
administration process and probate
proceedings
makes a non-substantive clarification to
the intestines statute
and make some clarifying changes to the
new hampshire uniform power of attorney
act and it also adopts the uniform
disclaimer property interest act with
the addition of some language requested
by the department of health and human
services
so i will say the creation of this bill
was done in collaboration with a group
of trust and estates attorneys they have
a legislative working group of about 45
trusted estates lawyers
in new hampshire so i will defer um this
is not my area of
expertise so i will defer all technical
questions on this portion to attorney
ben hillman from shaheen and gordon who
can describe the work that went into
developing this bill and answer some
technical questions on the policy
decisions made so i appreciate your time
thank you so much
does anyone have any questions for
senator whitley
sing none thank you senator for your
testimony today thank you mr chair
and
senator guida
hello senator
i think you may be muted if you're there
okay we will
move on
the
their
representative peter bixby
and good morning um
this is uh this is representative peter
bixby i represent uh stratfor district
17 which covers uh a portion of dover
and somersworth
and i am also the ranking member on the
house
environmental agriculture committee
and i'm just speaking to section 11 of
this bill
and
the
which is the section dealing with
industrial hemp and the initial
legislation that um
that is making it an amendment to
it uh came through our committee in 2015
i believe that uh representative simpson
might remember that uh the um
and uh
at that point it uh
uh the bill the 2015 bill gave uh
universities and the research
universities in the state the ability to
do research on hemp at that point uh
hemp was not otherwise legal in
uh
the um in the united based on u.s law
except as part of a
pilot program
uh so
um that was creating a possibility for
research
uh there was hesitancy at um
still at the university to do any
research on it because of
its ambiguous
status
and also because uh just in terms of
sorting out priorities i believe that
there is
there was some interest in being able to
contract out some of that uh research
growing uh which it brought about the
uh a bill last term uh that senator
senator carson put forward to
um
to amend it and allow contracts growing
the universities to do contract growing
uh so that they wouldn't necessarily be
doing it on university land
uh
the
so um
and i am entirely in support of that i'm
not quite sure how that's that interacts
with
the new laws at this at the federal
level which allow anybody to grow hemp
as long as they are licensed by the usda
or by their state if their state has an
inspection program new hampshire does
not have a state inspection program so
they would have to be licensed by the
usda
um my concern is that i had mentioned to
senator carson at some point
near
before the filing period last term
last fall
that
there needed to be a minor correction in
the
new hampshire statute that allows
uh growing hemp under federal federal
guidelines
that uh passed in uh hb 459 last um
last term and
uh
there was a drafty there was a error
there when i was writing that i didn't
realize that the federal governor
government does not have any licensing
for people who process or
uh or
or sell hemp they just have licensing
for growing and i had put in a
requirement that uh people be federally
licensed to grow
and um
to grow and process and uh and sell
and uh what this i
sent a letter to the committee by email
recommending a an amendment that would
cover that part of the law that would
just remove the uh three or four words
that require
the federal license that doesn't exist
for
grow for processing and selling
uh so
um
that is if you could you know
i assume there's going to be some
amendment on this bill so if you could
include that language in
your amendment that would be
very useful and it would just correct a
minor error that currently exists in
our statutes
and i'd be happy to take any questions
are there any questions for
representative bixby
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
representative joe shapiro
[Music]
representative shapiro hello can you
hear me we can
yes i would like to just speak to
section three of senate bill 134
as the
as the sponsor of the house bill
205 which is identical to section 3
regarding suspended sentences i just
want to make a few points
number one that this
bill does not change
the statute that's already in place
um
which allows people to petition to the
courts to have their
sentence suspended after serving
two-thirds of that sentence
it merely moves the time when people can
make that petition
um
to 12 months prior
and the reason for that why this is so
important
is that
by the time people requested
a hearing with the court by the time
people got that hearing with the court
many months would pass
and often
people who were petitioning the court
for suspended sentence would also have
to
complete programming rehabilitative
programming such as
substance abuse treatment programming in
the prison and they wouldn't be able to
get access to those
programs until they made the petition
and sometimes it would take up to a year
to complete those programs
so this um bill just allows people to
petition
earlier
so that they will actually be eligible
if the court
deems it so
to have their
sentence suspended after two-thirds of
their sentence
i would also like to say that the
original bill both in the senate and in
the house
called for 18 months prior
and that was objected to by
commissioner hanks of the um
corrections department
and that was negotiated down to 12
months which was agreeable to the
corrections department i would also like
to say that this the
this bill was initially
initiated by
men in the concord state prisons who
serve on the
rcc which is the um
resident communication committee
and these are men who've devoted their
time in prison to making the most of
their situation
who um
meet regularly and work on
issues that will make
people's sentences um useful to them as
opposed to just serving time and this is
a group of people who are really quite
impressive and are working hard and this
means a great deal to them so i hope you
will take that into account um in
regards to section three
thank you and i'm willing to take any
questions yes representative chase
yes thank you so much mr chair and thank
you representative shapiro for taking my
question
um
i personally have a situation where
someone is
incarcerated
because of defense on myself and um
they have to complete a program before
they're able to
pretend
before they're able to
do what you're talking about the
petition uh what i want to know is this
does not mean that they don't finish
their programs that they're supposed to
do correct it just means that they're
able to put their time in because i do
understand there is a backlog
of trying to get into programs
does that make sense
yes well my understanding is that um
you know this just gives people the
right to petition at a certain time
inmates the right to petition at a
certain time ultimately it's the court
that makes a decision about whether to
suspend their sentence okay and that
that generally involves
um people
having to complete certain programming
um
related to their particular issues
in order to have the court do that so it
doesn't change
what it would take to be eligible it
just changes the time when they can
petition it's really a very
simple
fix to a glitch in the system um
the statute to suspend people's
sentences after two-thirds is already
there
okay thank you so much
representative mclean
uh yeah uh thank you mr chairman thank
you for taking my question just so just
to clarify aside from uh the time period
which you negotiated the department of
corrections is fully on board with this
legislation
yes they are and when um house bill 205
the identical bill was heard um
in criminal justice
um
where although i didn't think it was
going to be controversial at all for
some reason it was retained
someone did come from the department of
corrections to say that 12 months
was something that they supported and i
think i probably have an email from
commissioner hanks
saying that as well which i could send
to your committee
thank you
are there any other questions for
representative shapiro
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you
and
i guess i'll just try again to see if
senator geider is there
i am here mr chairman okay
you're you're on
all right thank you very much mr
chairman uh and uh representatives uh i
am state senator bob geider representing
district two and prime sponsor of
section nine part nine of senate bill
this is a relatively simple bill
or simple part of the bill with an
extremely important component to it what
we do here is we're making an
appropriation
to fund mental health intervention
training for our law enforcement
officers
uh
as you may well know and i'm sure that
you do especially mr chairman um
in bath just a few years ago a young man
that was known to be suffering from some
mental problems
ultimately was shot and killed by police
the
shooting was ruled justified
but it was totally unnecessary there are
any number of points during that in
during that um a situation at which the
police officers with proper training
okay could have stopped the individual
and could have not had to use lethal
force
i'm sure you're familiar with the
incident that happened over in claremont
just less than a month ago
uh in which the young man was shot again
known to have mental problems and
ultimately the use of lethal force was
used when it was not necessary
justified
probably necessary not
and so what this bill will do is to
provide two hundred and ten thousand
dollars for the biennium
uh that ends june 30th of 23
uh for police officer training um by
police standards and training uh
overseen by them but provided by uh
nanny uh ken norton over at nami who i'm
pretty certain will testify as well in
favor of this the 210 000 figure
uh is arrived at because the current
funding for this program which is
excellent as we speak
expires at the end of the fiscal federal
year that would be september 30th
and so uh we're looking for a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars for each of
our fiscal years that would mean ninety
thousand dollars to the remainder of
fiscal uh
22 and into 120 000 additional for 23.
the fiscal note also states that uh
those funds we're not certain whether we
would use them equally in each of the
two years
uh so we leave that up to the training
folks at police standards and training
and to nami as they organize the
curriculum to continue to train more and
more of our police officers in mental
health intervention in situations
that would prevent the use of deadly
force and with answer i'll take any
questions
i i guess my only question senator is
why
a separate bill as opposed to just
including it in the budget or in the
provisions of house bill 2.
yeah i was approached by by ken norton
over at nanny uh to bring this in
as a separate provision and i think at
the at the end of the day down the road
we're going to try to make it a
permanent part of the budget
it's coming off of federal funding and
going into state funding at this point
in time
but it's money that i believe is well
spent
are there other questions for senator
gaida
see none
thank you for your testimony today
thank you
mr chairman
senator khan
signed up to testify but i don't see him
on the list of attendees
senator khan if you're there you could
raise your hand that would be helpful
i don't see
the next person to
testify would be
diana fenton
from the department of education
good morning
for the record my name is diana fenton
i'm an attorney with the department of
education uh as a quick aside i did just
send a text to senator khan letting him
know that
he's been sought after in house
judiciary and i'm sure he will join us
soon uh thank you members of the
committee it is a pleasure to be here
today in front of you my testimony
concerns section 8 of this bill
as it pertains to school employee and
school volunteer criminal history
background checks
this bill would amend rsa 189
colon 13a
and that is the law that governs
criminal history record checks for
teachers when they are hired by a school
district
in large part this bill provides clarity
and cleanup language to rsa 189 13 a
most notably the the bill makes uh the
time frame for the destruction of an
individual's criminal history record
it makes that consistent it is a 60-day
set time period
previously the bill as it is now the law
as it is now um
vacillates between immediate destruction
if there is no criminal history and 60
days if there is a criminal history
this was causing confusion to the field
and the department of safety also had
concerns about it just we wanted it to
be consistent so we made that 60-day
window
most notably
part 8
creates a new section of law rsa 189
13 little
this will allow the department of
education
to conduct a criminal background check
new teacher applicants
now currently
uh
when the department of education issues
a credential to someone to teach we do
not conduct a criminal history
background check
the criminal history background check is
done as part of employment
however last session house bill 1520 was
passed which granted the department
authority to conduct a criminal history
background check on new teaching
applicants
however there was some critical language
that was missing from that bill
and that language
is the language which allows the
department of safety to disseminate the
record to the department of education
and so that's what we have incorporated
into 189 13c
um in that same provision
we will also be doing the criminal
history uh background checks on
uh teaching candidates teacher prep
candidates who are at a higher eds
this was done in order to help higher
eds in partnership with the field
and um higher eds you have to understand
that the federal background check
is not
it cannot be disseminated to
non-governmental entities which are
private
higher eds
however the department of education is a
governmental entity
so we were hoping to partner with the
field and
really serve a significant need and
purpose
by assisting our higher eds and running
those teacher prep program candidates
and assisting them to get into the
placements at the districts so that they
can fulfill their their educational
requirements
the third part of the bill is a study
committee
to look at how the department of
education again with our
role as a governmental entity could
perhaps help
non-public schools or private schools
conduct criminal background checks on
employees because similar to the higher
ed's
non-public schools are not
authorized to receive the federal
background checks they can get the new
hampshire background checks
but they cannot get the federal
background checks and so this was just a
study committee to see what if any role
the department of education could play
to assist
to assist in that area the underlying
idea of course being child safety
thank you for your time today i'm happy
to take any questions
are there any questions for
miss benton or attorney fenway
i get
i guess the only question with regard to
the study committee at the end
is that something that's been requested
by the private schools how did how did
that become initiated
thank you for the question i i can't
speak directly to the origins of the
study committee i know that was um
something that senator khan was
interested in doing so i will defer to
him to talk about how this came about
but i i know that senator khan and i had
um a lot of discussions at is kind of
how to best utilize the department's
authority as a governmental agency and
how we can assist the field
i don't know if it was the non-publics
that requested that study committee
um but i do know that the underlying
concern was uh was child safety so i
will defer to senator khan and i'm sure
he will be joining us shortly
and i guess uh
just another question are there are
there any parts of this bill
that this session were heard by the
house previously
and
and and not look favorably upon
my understanding of the kind of
procedural history of this bill if you
will is it was in senate judiciary and
then came over obviously to house
judiciary to the best of my knowledge
this has not been in senate education
nor has it been in house education
thank you thank you
okay any other questions yes
representative chase
thank you mr chair and thank you the
attorney founded i'm just curious that
just seems crazy to me personally that
there
you can have someone come in as a
substitute
and not have had a background check done
until employment have there been any
issues with that
in the past that that's why this is
being put into the bill
thank you for the question i'm not aware
of any issues
necessarily i think this is just an
issue in general
that the department of education is
always looking to improve ways that we
can protect children
um
and one way we can do that we felt was
by
not just deferring entirely to
employment for the background checks
take a more active role in running the
background checks when we issue a
credential
excellent thank you thank you
representative sylvia
thank you mr chair and uh thank you for
taking my question is a a piece of the
legislation that speaks of uh destroying
records background check records uh
what's the intention behind this
thank you for the question
so
currently the way the law is is
the way the law is written is it
provides for the immediate destruction
of records if there is no criminal
history
uh reported
and it allows for 60-day
uh
60-day time frame to destroy the record
if there is a criminal history
and
we wanted to just make it a little
clearer get rid of that difference or
discrepancy if you will and just have
this 60-day time frame window
i also think in my discussions with the
department of safety and i don't want to
speak on their behalf but
um i think it it helps
them as well and i think the department
of education is the only state agency
that had that difference those different
time frame windows so we just went with
60 days
based on our discussions with the
department of safety to just make it
clear and consistent across the board
thank you
any other questions
for attorney clinton
saying none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you very much
and i do see senator khan's hand up here
greetings chairman gordon
good morning senator
members of the committee uh
this
worked out very well
uh you've heard from uh attorney fenton
and been able to ask her questions and
uh the department of education has been
intimately
involved in the writing of this
legislation
uh which they see as key to
conducting the background checks for
uh schools
so uh i'm glad to answer your questions
i i will address the
the
private school study
uh committee
um
i think we are all familiar with some
very high profile
uh private school
uh
cases uh
that have arisen in the last
half dozen years and uh this is not
presuming an outcome
this is offering
uh
a collaboration with
the private schools
that if there is a role that the
department of education can play in
conducting those background checks so
that they can provide
the information
to private schools much the same way
that ms fenton described
doing that for colleges for their
uh teacher preparation programs
then
then we would come forward with some
legislation if uh parties agreed that
this would be a benefit
but this is not presuming an outcome to
that
uh to that study
any questions for senator khan
senator carter i was wondering if on the
study committee we could make it three
senators and one rep
maybe maybe
i would leave that to the committee to
make
their best recommendations on it clearly
the the house with the number and the
talent of people that you have to to
select from
uh is much deeper than uh what we in the
senate have
any other questions for senator khan
yes representative chase
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
kahn for taking my question i'm just
curious and i had when i was reading
through this too about the um
destroying of records
i understand you have the right to do
that but what is the reason for it
especially if somebody is um actually
has offenses and that
is information that
kind of a right to know you know i mean
enough other other schools should know
about or families should know about what
why would they be destroyed
yes
thanks for that question i hope ms
fenton is still on the line in case
there's anything that i fail to
answer correctly here but but
while that is destroyed by the local
district it is the local district's
responsibility to be sharing
any offenses
in section 5 of 189
that
any offenses
with the
department of education and the
commissioner so prior to any destruction
uh and and that's that the records don't
uh
aren't revealed to
uh people who don't have a reason to to
look at those
the reason for background check is
initial employment
and and then
the department of education retains that
information
uh should there be any further initial
employment requests on that person by
another district
okay thank you for clarifying that
any other questions for the senator
[Music]
cnn thank you for your testimony today
thank you i'll get back to my committee
thank you very much
take care
and we have uh
next on the last list chief david
goldstein
good morning mr chairman good morning
and members of the committee uh for the
record my name is david goldstein and
i'm currently the chief of police for
the city of franklin new hampshire i
have been a police officer for more than
41 years
i began my i began my career with the
derry police department and after three
years there
transferred over and moved over to the
new hampshire state police so i spent 23
years
involved in a number of different
assignments and retiring with the rank
of captain
i've been a police chief for 16 years
the last 11 here in the city of franklin
i'm also the legislative committee chair
for the new hampshire association of
chiefs of police
i hold the ba in psychology and ms in
public health and a phd in counseling
and human services with a concentration
in forensic traumatology
i've been an adjunct instructor at the
new hampshire police academy for over 35
years
and instructed both the recruit and
in-service levels
in such topics as stress and critical
incident management working with
emotionally disturbed individuals and
forensic psychology
i've also taught similar topics at
various academies in the state of
massachusetts
i've held in do hold adjunct
professorships concerned with mental
health issues at such institutions as
boston university both on the
undergraduate and graduate levels
new england college the college for
lifelong learning excuse me and new
hampshire technical institute
i'm also on the faculty of the
criticalness and team training
facilitated by nami new hampshire
i've been a guest lecturer for
specific mental health issues at grand
rounds for the department of emergency
psychiatry at the then tufts new england
medical center and our own new hampshire
hospital
i've signed in neutral relative to this
bill as a whole but i'm here today to
testify in support of section 9 of sb
thus making an appropriation for funding
mental health intervention training
programs and i ask that you vote ought
to pass on section 9.
thank you and i will be happy to answer
any questions you might have
any questions for the chief
thank you chief
my pleasure take care
next person to testify is virginia
sheehan
can you hi can you hear me we can okay
um good morning mr chairman and
committee
um my name is virginia sheehan and i
have been practicing as an estate
planning probate and trust attorney
since 1990. i am here to support passage
of
senate bill 134 in particular parts two
and seven
you will hear some of my state planning
colleagues
also
testify regarding these two parts
as to part two
as you have heard
from the bill's sponsor
the purpose of part two is to allow
remote real estate closings and the
legislation is based on model statutes
the revised uniform law notorious acts
and their uniform real property
electronic recording act that have been
enacted in many other states
you'll hear more testimony from other
people on those
on the the statute in general
those statutes in general but i'm here
to testify primarily
on two small sections of part two
part two also includes provisions to
make legislation passed last summer
authorizing remote notarization of
estate planning documents
such as wills and trusts and remote
witnessing of wills permanent
the current statute expires when the
open 19 state of emergency ends
but this statute as uh passed last year
there were two
statutes that were amended to allow us
to do this
has really provided estate planners new
hampshire state planners with the
ability to serve many clients during the
pandemic who would otherwise not have
completed their estate plans due to
medical concerns and also it allowed us
to keep many others safe during the
process of signing estate planning
documents
during which you need a notary for most
of them you need a notary and two
witnesses so it's kind of a big group of
people
and although many of us have found
creative ways to
function during the pandemic meeting
outside
and all sorts of other
creative things to do mostly meeting
outside but in large rooms or whatever
there are many estate planning clients
who would not have
been able to sign documents
that were able to sign them because we
were able very safely based on how these
two amendments were drafted last year
and passed
to assist them to sign their documents
remotely so this statute part two of the
statute also includes provisions to make
those
provisions permanent and that's that's
what i'm supporting
to allow us to continue to use these
there's going to be many other
there's going to be many other health
situations that clients are in and many
times it is very difficult to get into
hospitals or to get into nursing homes
to assist people and this is a really
wonderful tool
the other part of my testimony is in
support of part 7.
as you heard
there is a group of estate planning
attorneys
and probate practitioners who
we've been meeting
we just meet
over the last few years and looking at
different parts of the practice that
could use improvement um this part seven
contains several
of those um amendments and
that we would
like to have
made and this bill was passed last year
as and was put in as part of a
omnibus bill that was then vetoed
so the um
this part simplifies the probate
administration it expands the simplified
probate administration known as waiver
of administration
and makes several corrections to the
intestines and durable power of attorney
statutes those are really just pretty
much typos and several clarifications
and it also updates the uniform
displaying of property interest act to a
more current um act ours is very very
old
um um as i said these changes were
passed by the senate last year but
unfortunately they were
they were um part of the covid um
issues with vetoes and omnibus bills and
um
we
as part of our process when we look at
potential statutes that affect the
probate practice we contact judge king
to make sure that what we are doing is
consistent with what the court would
approve and he is fully supportive
of
these changes especially the changes to
the waiver of administration statute
that directly impact the court the
waiver of administration changes will
simplify the probate process for new
hampshire citizens while continuing the
oversight of the court if necessary
which is really it's a great system we
have here
many states have fully unsupervised
probate we don't have that we have
unsupervised probate unless the port
needs to get involved
so this will save time and money for
both new hampshire citizens and new
hampshire circuit court probate probate
division and we
fully support passage thank you for your
consideration
any questions for attorney sheehan
cnn thank you for your testimony
thank you mr chairman
and next person to testify would be
attorney robert wells
any wells you might have to unmute
my name is robert wells i live in
hopkinton new hampshire and i've been
practicing in the field of trust and
state law for 50 years
uh
with respect to what ginger sheen just
testified i do not want to repeat what
she said but i will generally support
all of her comments both with section 2
and section 7.
with respect to section 7 this goes back
almost four years that we've been
working with judge king
uh to make the changes for waiver of
probate and as ginger indicated it is a
savings for both
the court as well as our clients
and i can give you a specific example i
have a will now where their two children
are the beneficiaries and the two
children are the executors waiver of
probate is not available
because
under current law has to be a single
executor and a single person single
beneficiary
so with that we have to go through full
probate unnecessarily with this new
provision
uh new provisions as is set forth in
section seven this
greatly simplifies matter one of the
other provisions in this provides that a
probate judge may in his discretion or
her discretion
allow waiver of probate and that can
happen sometimes when the only probate
asset for example is an automobile and a
single person has died right now we have
to go through full probate to get the
car
into a trust when we have a pour over
will into a revocable trust
with respect to section two um my
experience in dealing with the
zoom execution of documents
has been uh
life-changing in many ways having
practiced for so long with having to
meet people in rooms and conferences
many times people had to travel great
distances sometimes people were not well
and what we have found with respect to
the remote signing under the emergency
order is great uh satisfaction from the
client base uh with respect to the
execution of these documents and
typically only when i would call
ordinary documents if there is an
exclusion of a child
in an estate plan or other problems that
could create issues most attorneys are
still insisting on face-to-face uh
execution of those documents but for all
practical purposes what i will refer to
as our somewhat standard
documents uh
this has worked just uh
i can't express myself
how happy i have been able to continue
to work with zoom for advancing my
clients interests happy to answer any
questions
any questions returning well yes
attorney mcgrane
not an attorney
yes representative mclean excuse me i
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
for me um probate law is very confusing
so just bear with me
with the waiver
of administration the case that you
cited where you're dealing with a case
where you have two heirs
and the person died
intestate so in the past
that would have to go to probate now it
does not
is am i correct in what you were saying
what happens is that uh is respect to
both whether you have a will or
intestines either one the new statute
applies to both
so if you have two
children who are the co-executors named
in the will and they are the
beneficiaries
currently waiver of probate is not
available
with the new statute assuming it passes
now what will happen is a simplified
process by which they simply apply for a
petition to have themselves appointed as
executors and with that document they
are able to advance all aspects of the
transfer of assets without filing an
inventory without filing a bond
uh
and without any court supervision
because why should two people who are in
charge who are the beneficiaries why
does the court have to become involved
and that would be true for intestacy or
with respect to test date if you have
say five or six children
and they are all beneficiaries uh under
those circumstances
the five or six beneficiaries can agree
that one or two of the children could
serve as executors and in that case in
addition waiver of probate would apply
yes representative mclean just a quick
follow-up and again i'm ignorant so if
um
in the case of
an intestacy where you're trying to
understand
i thought probate was to determine who
are the claimants so maybe it's not
clear that there are the five claimants
and so maybe there's
um a sixth person
but if you if you can wave it does that
not give the opportunity for that to go
forward
well that is not correct a waiver of the
intestine is determined by state law
and state law determines who the
beneficiaries are so it's always clear
who the beneficiaries are okay
i'll thank you for clarifying that
are there any other questions for
attorney wells
see none thanks for your testimony today
thank you
it's um
donald
sinkowitz
he's available
[Music]
signed up but apparently
not here if you're there raise your hand
i got a statement preservation of
planning
yep there we go
mute hello hi there sorry for i am
donaldson kevin my my business is a
state preservation planning i apologize
for the deceptive zoom label
uh everyone can hear me we can
um i
uh mr chairman representatives thanks i
i won't uh repeat much of what my
colleagues uh virginia sheehan and bob
wells have just said
but i'll tell you that in my estate
planning practice i have been doing
remote signings uh for 13 months and
they've been very effective and very
secure and i would be very grateful if
the
committee would vote
ought to pass i am in support of section
two also in support of section seven but
speaking in support of section two and
uh i'll simply ask if the committee has
any questions about uh our proposed
process for remote estate planning
signing and making it permanent
are there any questions
seeing none thank you for your brief
testimony it's much appreciated
my pleasure thank you
uh inner goulet zimmerman
i am here can you hear me you can all
right thank you i'm talking today on
section six the collaborative law act uh
mr chair members of the committee i
appreciate your time and the opportunity
to speak my name is anna goulet
zimmerman and i'm an attorney in
manchester and a member of the new
hampshire law alliance
only a small part of my practice is
currently family law but i've been
involved with
this bill since its inception working
with a bipartisan group of family law
attorneys and i've stayed involved as
i've always thought we should be doing
whatever we can to help resolve family
law matters fairly and amicably and with
a minimum of damage to the children and
family impacted this is not always
possible but if both parties are willing
this law would allow another process
what would codify another process
whereby this can happen
as senator carson said this is a
voluntary alternative dispute process
both parties would need to need to agree
to participate so how does it work and
what is collaborative what law
it's basically a process whereby
everyone commits to the collaborative
process they sign a contract an
agreement at the beginning they have
attorneys who or they should have
attorneys who are trained in
collaborative law
there's usually a coach who's like a
mental health provider a counselor who
helps
kind of facilitate discussions work
through difficult issues things like
that
and if the process falls apart before
going to court everyone needs to get a
new attorney so everybody's committing
at the beginning to
a resolution outside of court with the
exception of course that the court still
retains the right to have a final
overview of the family law agreements
and to approve those
the purpose is to have everybody working
together in a way that can positively
reach
agreed results looking at alternatives
looking at what financial situations can
be made working through together how to
best address parenting issues
it's private so if people don't want to
be in court discussing their finances
and things like that they can do it in
this type of a setting
it allows a detailed analysis of a bunch
of different options that might not be
available in a traditional trial setting
um you know
having a financial planner work through
with both parties what their futures
might look like under certain scenarios
things like that and the idea is to
really reduce litigation and conflict um
because everybody signed in on the
process the attorneys can't be saying
you know well forget this i'm just gonna
go to court tomorrow um there are
exceptions obviously if there's
emergencies
um
you know there's a process you'll see in
the bill to look for and make sure
there's no domestic violence issues or
that everybody's in a safe situation
when we're doing this
uh and this is a process that is in pro
is in practice right now
um but we're asking to have it codified
because i think we think it's important
that everyone be following by the same
rules that everyone agree that the
agreements reached can be enforced just
like they would be if we were in
mediation that the process remains
confidential because although we're
saying it's confidential you know that's
just the participants you know right now
there's not a way to necessarily require
that or enforce that um in court and
it's that in that regard it's very like
much like the current mediation process
except there's multiple people usually
involved because we do often have
financial planners and the coach
in my experience these are my favorite
cases because i come away with everyone
feeling okay about the results everyone
has kind of a vested interest in
what did we reach we work this out
together and it's a great feeling if
you're a family law attorney and one you
don't get very often to walk away from a
case like that i think it's good for
families i think it's good for
individuals i think it's good for the
court because it reduces litigation for
people who don't want to do it they
don't have to do it it's not a process
anyone's being required to do
and i'd ask for your support of the bill
i'm happy to take any questions
okay uh attorney
representative macbeth sorry
good morning thank you mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question
attorney zimmerman um in full disclosure
i support this bill i've been a member
of the new hampshire collaborative law
alliance and they're also some of my
favorite cases
i have i do have three questions um i
wanted to know if participants um in the
collaborative process if the parties are
still required to provide the financial
disclosures um that are required under
family rule 2 um
1.25 a
so i think the answer is just like um
that rule they i mean they normally are
normally we're exchanging far more
than that but i think just like that
rule the parties could agree to waive or
reduce what's exchanged you know under
the current rules we can agree just to
exchange a financial affidavit for
example
the courts are still going to require as
part of the filings of financial
affidavit before they approve any any
any
um
any of the agreements any parenting
plans any you know that's just a
requirement of the courts so i think the
answer is
yes but the courts you know just like in
court people could agree to um
wave part or all of that my experience
has been that usually more is exchanged
um than the required amounts
i have a follow-up yep thank you mr
chair um and the other issue is what
about um
the you know the anti-hypothecation
clause and also the um
the date i mean if it's if it's outside
of the court and it's not going to be
brought forward what is the date then
that is set for the separation of some
marital property like a pension or
something like that well maybe you're
already six months forward
um is is that negotiated amongst the
parties as well as the anti-apothecation
clause or what happens with that thank
you i'm glad you asked that question
because that's one of the things one of
the issues where i think is really
important about this law
because i know that if i was the pension
holder or the 401k holder i might say
look i don't want to spend the next nine
months negotiating out all these things
because my pension and your interest in
my pension is growing every day
and the other side can say well let's
agree then
that for the purpose of dividing your
pension
this will be the day of you know the
same as the day of filing for example
because right now pensions get divided
based on when the divorce was filed
so we agree that when this gets done the
pension date for the person purpose of
hodgkin's which is the main case talking
about pensions um is the date we signed
this collaborative law agreement or the
date we signed this agreement in the
process
and this would allow the court that to
be an enforceable agreement within the
court
as opposed to just kind of uh yeah let's
hope that hope that works
and same with child support because no
one wants to come back and you know
waive child support necessarily for 10
months if that's how long the process is
working so that could all be built into
the early on agreements these are the
dates we're going to use for this this
is what part of the process is
thank you thank you very much no thank
you for the questions
any other questions
i guess the question i have is uh it
says a collaborative lawyer means a
lawyer who represents a party in a
collaborative
process
are there any
restrictions or qualifications on
who can be a collaborative lawyer
so we have had training in it um i have
i went to a continuing legal education
course on it and i continue to have a
certain number of
hours each year that that we all do
um it's not
necessarily a requirement
that i'm aware of like there's no
overseeing body like the bar association
or something that says that in order to
be a member of the collaborative law
alliance of new hampshire you do have to
have that though and that's usually
where people are looking for attorneys
and i know i always look to make sure
that the attorney on the other side of
my case is a collaboratively trained
lawyer
within that organization or or a similar
organization
part of the benefit again of the law
would be that if there was someone
participating who didn't have that
process because there's not again really
a policing agency they also now are
bound by and have this kind of framework
of what their what the process is and
what they're required to do if there
were other attorneys who you're like a
mediator who decided they wanted to
start doing collaborative work or
something like that
if i just maybe i'll ask the question a
different way and that is
there's
any attorney
could hold themselves out to be a
collaborative lawyer
as long as they follow the process
that's provided in this new chapter
i believe so
i again um as the attorney on the other
side i would probably choose not to work
with that attorney and tell my client
that if that's who who their their
significant other is going to have i had
some concerns because they weren't
collaboratively trained or i might want
to talk with that attorney before
deciding i would i would move ahead with
the case with that attorney and try to
get a better idea of what's their
background as far as mediation dispute
resolution and things of that nature
you know there are some attorneys who
are very litigious and i think taking a
very litigious attorney into the
collaborative law association law
process would pretty much
definitely uh
make it a short process for that case
and i wouldn't be serving my client in
those instances
but there's nothing fundamentally that
i'm aware of and that's just me
individually that would prevent someone
from saying yes i want to i want to do
collaborative work
and i guess the other ques collaborative
law has been around for a long time
is this the first time that this
type of
formality has been proposed you know
it was part of an omnibus bill last year
that got vetoed for i think other
reasons um it was it's been it's been
non-controversial in both in both
hearings that we had last year on it
um i said it's it's bipartisan it's
voluntary on the who can participate by
the way i would add that the same goes
for mediators i could tomorrow hang out
my shingle and say hey i'm going to
start mediating cases
um and then people get to decide if they
think i'm i'm worth coming to mediate
cases with
um
so
that that that part isn't necessarily
unique to this bill but yes this is it
it was it was part of an omnibus which
became i believe the issue last time
um for not not reasons associated with
this bill
thank you
any other questions
thank you attorney for your testimony
today
i appreciate the time
and
benjamin syracusa hillman
so i'm here
if you're there you could raise your
hand
uh brian deere
good morning
mr chairperson members of the committee
thank you very much for allowing me to
testify my name is brian dear for the
record i'm the executive director of the
national association of settlement
purchasers
here to speak in support of part five of
the bill
relating to
creating a new hampshire structured
settlement protection act
what this part of the bill would do
would
bring new hampshire into alignment with
the other 49 states in the district of
columbia of having
its own structured settlement protection
act
what this would do would to
basically provide the framework
for individuals in new hampshire who are
interested in
who are receiving structured settlement
payments as a result of a
a personal injury accident a wrongful
death case or a variety of never matters
basically provides the framework for
those individuals in new hampshire
to go through a
court approval process
essentially
so that in this case a third party in
this case a judge in new hampshire would
review the transaction
and
essentially make sure that the
transaction is going to be in the
structured settlement recipient's best
interest and the best interest of their
dependents
this
section part five is based off of
the encoil model the most recent
variation which is what most of the
state statutes
that are put into place in the other
states are based off of the encoil model
it is a
very
is a finely tuned
statute that has been put together and
refined over the years since its
inception essentially to make sure that
there are consumer protections for
individuals in this process to make sure
that
all the parties that necessarily need to
receive
a notice of these transactions receive
notice and just make sure that you know
new hampshire citizens uh have a
um very thorough uh but very protective
process when they're in these
transactions
um what
this part 5 will do is essentially make
sure that all new hampshire citizens
have a uniformed law that
governs these transactions
currently
since new hampshire does not have a
structured settlement protection act if
a new hampshire citizen wishes to
proceed with one of these transactions
they actually have to import the law of
a different state
so that a
a new hampshire citizen had a
transaction where an insurance company
was based in texas or california
uh or delaware or wherever that
insurance company may be to move forward
with one of these transactions they
currently have to import the law of that
state
and some of the state laws vary wildly
so that new hampshire citizens you know
currently would have to go through
whatever that particular state's
requirements uh the passage of this
portion of the omnibus bill would make
sure that new hampshire has its own
law
uh
with all of the up-to-date current
protections that the encoil model
affords
to make sure that all new hampshire
citizens are treated
you know similarly and have the same
similar consumer protections that this
bill would provide
uh there was uh some input that we
received uh from the judiciary uh i
believe the amendment uh that
representative burch uh referenced
earlier on in this committee hearing uh
the amendment essentially addresses the
concerns he judiciary brought up
essentially one of the things in one of
the disclosures that
each new hampshire citizen who wants to
enter into one of these transactions
uh we're adding an additional disclosure
in that amendment essentially making
sure that new hampshire citizens uh you
know understand that they have the right
essentially to receive multiple offers
from different companies to make sure
that when they're going through this
process um that they consider if they
wanted to do so to shop around and make
sure they're getting the best
price possible for the payments they're
wishing to sell
and it's also making sure that the
judiciary takes in back consideration to
make sure when they're deciding whether
or not uh this transaction is going to
be in a best interest that they have had
the opportunity to shop around again if
the citizen wishes to do so
uh there will be a number of other uh
you know
stakeholders who will be testifying
later today my colleague jack kelly will
be telling you a little bit more about
the history uh in addition to being the
executive director of the trade
association i am also a practicing
attorney in this space
in the state of texas so i'm very
familiar with the mechanics on how these
cases operate so that if any members of
the committee have any specific
questions as far as the mechanics of how
this statute would work i can certainly
address those questions and i'm happy to
take any questions that the committee
has but we are certainly in support of
this bill and we hope that the
committee would uh act favorably upon
part five of this bill
are there any
questions for mr dear
see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen
uh john diana
good morning chairman gordon and members
of the committee um thank you for this
opportunity to speak in support of
section 10 of the bill relative to
employer access to motor vehicle records
as it was amended and came out of the
senate
my name is john diana and i'm the
general counsel and chief compliance
officer of samba safety
my company
serves over 100 000 employers in the us
and canada and our singular mission is
to help employers
improve driver safety and road safety
and
motor vehicle records are the most
important part of a any employer safety
policy
um just to clarify a motor vehicle
record provides two pieces of critical
information for anybody who employs
drivers
one is whether they have a valid license
at any time
so does is that person properly licensed
to drive
secondly it provides their
record of violations
dui speeding running a red light etc
it's important to clarify there is no
alternative to a motor vehicle record
for employer so the only opportunity for
an employer to make sure that they have
qualified drivers that are not a risk to
the public behind the wheel is to
acquire a motor vehicle record
and i just want to share some critical
stats to emphasize how important these
records are
94 of accidents are the result of human
behavior five percent of accidents
involve a driver with an invalid
driver's license
19 of fatalities involve a driver
without a valid driver's license
26 percent of fatalities involve
speeding
and alcohol is a contributing factor in
of accidents
the reason uh for this bill
it for section 10 is that the dmv
currently interprets new hampshire law
to
require
an employer to have a notarized form on
an individualized basis
filed with the dmv in order to acquire a
record on a employee
new hampshire is the only state with
this restriction
and it is impractical costly and time
consuming for employers
it makes it substantially more likely
that an employer will not pull a motor
vehicle record and will put a driver
behind the wheel that is a danger to the
public
um
we've uh my company has
engaged with the dmv
for
well over a year on this issue and the
dmv encouraged collaboration with the
state legislature for a solution
so section 10 does a few really
important things it permits electronic
access for employers and their agents
it will benefit employers contributing
to improve road safety and ultimately
help reduce accidents in new hampshire
and it will maintain federal and state
protections for individuals
most importantly no employer can pull
the dmv record of an employee without a
written consent from that employee so
they have to provide them notice in
advance and receive written
authorization to pull that record um
that's all and thank you very much for
this opportunity to speak to you
okay uh representative oregon do you
have a question
uh sure i don't know if it's the right
place to address it but i
the commercial driver's license
isn't mentioned specifically in part 10
from my understanding is and
and uh
you may i may i may be misinterpreting
what i thought i read but the commercial
drivers licenses um
they routinely
uh check the uh motor v
your record more stringently than they
do for somebody who's a regular driver's
license and part of the reason why this
bill supposedly is necessary
i think from what i've seen is that
uh people are more people are being
hired as drivers for hire who aren't uh
they're driving vehicles that require a
commercial driver's license or also
there's also don't
have to go to the restrictions for uh
for
transporting students or for being a
taxi driver so would uh
what would another solution maybe be to
expand
uh who
who needs a commercial driver's license
to be employed as a be hired as a driver
thanks not sure but hopefully i made
myself reasonably clear no thank you uh
and i fully understand the question and
i will
agree with you you're absolutely right
that
there is a
there's a population of drivers that are
currently unregulated that are growing
very fast in the state and for example
are drivers for like doordash instacart
if you're driving full-time for a
company like that you may drive in
excess of a hundred thousand miles
and uh
unlike a driver of a tractor trailer
you're not specifically trained for
commercial driving so it's even more
important to have access to a motor
vehicle record
regarding the question about commercial
licenses those are generally determined
by federal law so the
department of transportation
provides requirements for what is a
commercial driver's license and the
endorsements required in training and
other requirements i think it would be a
challenge
to try to pull all commercial drivers
under a commercial license because the
requirements are so
individual whether they
transport hazmat materials etc so i
think this is a this bill is a very
flexible way to
ensure employers can qualify their
drivers
okay yeah thanks and in the interest of
full disclosure i actually currently
hold a cdlb license myself even though i
haven't driven anything larger than a
volvo in about 15 years
partially it's just a matter of pride
i've spent a lot of effort learning to
parallel park a box and so um
thank you and thank you mr dan for
taking my question just so i'm clear on
this would these be records that could
be pulled from across the country or is
it just specifically your driver record
in new hampshire
it's just your driving record in new
hampshire so
each state dmv
maintains the record on their licensed
drivers in their state
so this
this record would only provide the
driving record in new hampshire although
through reciprocity if i have a license
in new hampshire and i have a serious
infraction in massachusetts
uh the only way to be aware of that is
that massachusetts would share that
information with the new hampshire dmv
and it would appear on my driving record
okay thank you that was exactly where
the thanks
representative silvia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh you earlier uh
stated some uh statistics
did those apply to
drivers in general or commercial drivers
oh those are those apply to drivers in
general so that's the
us population of drivers
and uh follow-up mr chairman yes you may
thank you um
so i'm trying to
figure how this is going to work is
there going to be
a number of companies holding all of
this data or is this going to be
centralized in one particular place
yeah
thank you for that and i can speak to
that because um we assist employers in
other states
so generally it's up to the state to
determine an appropriate contractual
term for the employer or an agent
acquiring the record on behalf of the
employer
um
so you know that's
my experience it's always a written
contract it requires compliance it
covers things like retention of records
restrictions on use
i would also point out that federal law
the driver's privacy protection act and
the fair credit reporting act
limit use of a record like a driving
record to
the singular use of screening an
employer for qualification
so the law already prohibits use of that
information for marketing for any other
purpose other than the express
requirement to screen a eligible driver
thank you
representative horgan did you have
another question
i just forgot to lower my hand
i'll i'll lower it now thank you thank
you representative mclean thank you mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so with the exception of going from
requiring uh the notarized form
the electronic delivery
is that the only change so here we have
uh the direct the consent is retained
for a three year period and it goes
through the
type of information that would be
gathered
so all of those things
are in line with the the prior statute
the only thing you're saying like the
three years is the same the amount of
information is all the same it's just
the mode of delivery that's different
yes uh agree out with one proviso
um
there is a portion of section 10
that further permits the state to
provide ongoing um
uh updates to records to an employer so
if i hire somebody today
and they receive a dui or their license
is suspended in a month
it would enable the department to
provide some sort of update file that
would say hey this record has changed
and uh you as an employer should be
aware of that
but
yes to answer your question directly
these are already public records
employers can access them it's just very
burdensome today
thank you
thank you any other questions
mr diane thank you for your testimony
representative chase did you have a
question yes i'm so sorry thank you i'm
just curious how long does it take to
get these records so that when you're
hiring somebody what's your wait time
before they can start
yeah that's uh thank you for asking that
because one of the key benefits to
employers in addition to improving
safety of their drivers
and avoiding the
legal risk of an accident with an
unqualified driver is the wait time
right so electronic access would allow
an employer to screen same time same day
pull a record automatically read that
record and make a hiring decision on the
spot
having to file a notarized release go
down to the dmv and get a copy of a
record could take days or weeks
perfect thank you
any other questions for mr diana
saying that again thank you for your
testimony today thank you
i have uh right now it's 10 39 i think
we just need to take just a very brief
recess to uh and we'll reconvene at 10
50. that will give us 11 minutes
just to refresh ourselves and we'd be
we'll start promptly at 10 50.
working on my house this weekend
okay we will reconvene our hearing on
senate bill 134
and our next speaker
would be zachary told
yes good morning i'm attorney zachary
toll
i'm with the new hampshire office of the
attorney general i'm with the debt
recovery unit and i'm speaking today in
support of sb 134 specifically part four
dealing with the
department of transportation
amendments to rsa23639
i'm actually the attorney who goes
through and does a lot of the collection
work for the department of
transportation and uh the purpose behind
this
amendment is to clean up some of the
language uh to reflect more what the
courts have
been doing with this statute
specifically ensuring that how the
language does provide is a strict
liability statute
while at the same time clarifying that
the damages that are included in this
statute are not just damages to the
highway itself as in tarmac but also any
uh guardrails signage
uh any other materials that the state or
municipality would own
that are involved with the highway
itself
uh earlier it was mentioned that there
was a proposed amendment uh that
amendment would be the addition of some
language that would ensure that this
statute would apply both to
forthcoming
accidents that we need to collect on but
also a
series of accidents that have occurred
in the past few years well within its
depth limitations
uh just to ensure that we can still
collect on those accidents
uh specifically
we're looking to ensure that we could
move forward on all of these accidents
based on estimates of the damages that
have occurred
instead of just on the actual defined
damages
d.o.t can give better details on their
actual process than i can but
whenever we do pursue litigation we are
seeking
as precise damages as we can uh dot
though because they do purchase items in
both because they do take time to
correct things and to actually fix some
of the damages that occur uh it can take
quite a while for them to determine what
the actual damages are and oftentimes
when everything is done in mass it can
be very difficult to determine
what were the damages for this specific
collision
when they repaired several collisions
that all happened within that month
allowing my office to pursue
the reasonable estimates which dod has
an entire process for calculating that
is the typical manner of
issuing invoices do cause damages uh
would allow the process to be much more
streamlined and allow us to actually act
within the statute of limitations
with a number that does reasonably
compensate d.o.t for the damages it has
to repair
uh i'm available to answer any questions
anyone may have
are there any questions for attorney
toll
representative mclean yeah thank you mr
chair and thank you attorney told the
the strict liability that you're
bringing in is that in line with other
states or
how do other states
handle that liability
uh off it's on my head i couldn't speak
to how other states handled that uh
obviously we focus on what's occurring
in new hampshire uh what i can say
though is the original language for the
bill said that anyone who damages any
part of the highway shall be liable
uh the courts have interpreted that here
in new hampshire to be strict liability
uh the amendment for the strict
liability component would be merely us
adding the word
shall be strictly liable so that way
it's more clear to anyone who goes to
read the bill anyone who may have
questions about it and just kind of save
time in the court instead of having to
rehash that issue every time
thank you
yeah i had just a couple questions if i
could
when i read the bill
and this is in the current language i
think uh of the bill
it
it says if any person without authority
shall place any obstruction in a highway
or cause any defect insufficiency
or want a repair of a highway which
renders it unsuitable for public travel
and the question is
i had when i read that is
so you damage a guard rail does that
make the highway unsuitable for public
travel
yes i believe so sir uh those safety
features are in place for a reason every
time they are damaged and compromised we
do increase the likelihood of someone
either injuring or killing themselves
someone else or causing further damage
to some other component of the hybrid
system
and
the other
the other question i have and apparently
with your what you're trying to do is to
do
is to apply
this new amendment retroactively to
existing claims as i understand it is
that correct that is correct and
is that a i guess the question is is it
appropriate to change the law to now
make people who would not otherwise be
liable liable for something they did in
the past
so uh
without having to go into too much
detail for you sir uh the way the courts
typically look at statutes as to whether
they are going to be retrospective or
maybe proactive uh looks to the nature
of the amendment of the statute uh
whether it is remedial or whether it is
affecting some substantive rights
after working with d.o.t on this we
believe this would actually be a
remedial
correction of the statute
no new liability is incurred
based on changing this from reliability
or in making this
uh to apply to all the accidents that
have been occurring over the past year
where we haven't been collection on them
because of
this incongruency between
the estimates and actual damages
uh it's remedial because
these individuals are still liable for
damaging any part of the highway
uh now it's just a matter of determining
how exactly those damages are being
calculated
that alteration i would contend
falls within the remedial nature of any
retroactive law which is legal under
the new hampshire constitution
and i i guess my final question is
i was under the impression that this
same language was in the budget builds
either house bill 1 or house bill 2
did it not pass in those bills
it's my understanding that uh d.o.t
attempted to get that amended language
put in uh i'm not entirely sure why it
didn't pass through with those so that
would have to be a question for eot
directly
thank you representative macbeth
thank you mr chair and thank you
attorney child for taking my question
and for being here with us this morning
um i too um share um the question that
my form my colleague rhett mclean
mentioned about
um what other states their policy i
understand we have an existing policy
but i think
um
this change to strict liability or
clarifying that certainly is significant
um and if i could also follow up i
wonder how many cases are you currently
in uh negotiation or litigation with
with this effect
if we changed it to retroactive
thank you
oh of course so
the way that the uh debt recovery unit
works is that these matters are referred
to my office once d.o.t has gone through
the proper procedure trying to collect
on it and they've been unable to for any
number of reasons
so
what i can speak to is the number of
cases i currently have that i'm aware of
a d.o.t can give a better detail of what
backlog they may have that they have not
referred to my office yet because of
waiting to see where this build will go
and seeing what the collection
applications will be
at the moment i have i believe should be
six or seven uh dot matters which are in
litigation but are currently being
suspended we just haven't done anything
with them we're just kind of waiting to
see where exactly uh the collection
language is going to land
uh those matters there at the moment uh
they're all kind of suspended just
because the defendants aren't responding
so we have just chosen not to report on
defaults
and then i also have probably 20 that
have been referred to my office they're
all still within the statute of
limitations
but we are once again holding off to see
whether we would be allowed to move
forward with the estimates or we have to
do the actual damages
in both cases the liability is there
based on the evidence it's just a matter
of determining whether we can use the
estimates that have been calculated and
dispatched to these
uh individuals who damage the highways
or if we need to find a way to calculate
the actual damages by
going through all of the mass purchases
and much larger expenditures that dlt
has done you see if we can send out the
actual damage for one guardrail person's
the entire stretch of highway that was
repaired at one time
yes
representative macbeth did you have a
follow-up yes i do thank you mr chairman
and um
i i
attorney i'm just i i'm this is a new
issue for me and i
i'm just clarifying so um
i think most of the people that are
uh damaging our highways there's
they're individuals these are
individuals
and
i imagine a guardrail could be hundreds
of thousands of dollars to replace if it
was damaged is that what we're talking
about we're talking about
um people having accidents on the road
and then them being
strictly liable for any damage to
highway signs and guardrails and
bridges
yes ma'am that is exactly what we're
talking about uh to clarify though we
are not talking in the hundreds of
thousands of dollars and
while there are many individuals
individuals i'd say make up a large
percentage of those who use guardrails
uh it also falls to businesses many
businesses operate on the highways a lot
of vehicles and many of them because of
their size when they hit something they
cause much higher damage
uh ultimately the way that the
calculations are currently occurring is
it's based on individual units of the
dark rail so when you drive down the
highway you'll obviously see perhaps a
mile long guardrail
um if an individual will strike that
they only get charged with a portion
that actually needs to be prepared
sometimes that's as little as a couple
hundred dollars it could be a very easy
pop it off and put in something new
or sometimes people strike specialty
parts regard rails specifically the
start and end portions which are extra
reinforced to help support and to
mitigate impact when they are struck
those can cost a few thousand dollars
uh
but it really depends on the
level of the strike that happens uh
sometimes people hit them and knock them
out for a couple hundred yards
that's much pricier than someone who
just has a fender bender and ends up
bending for one of the cardboards a
little bit so there's a wide range
and ultimately it does it does
differently between individuals striking
it and businesses and bearings
representative chase
oh i'm sorry representative macbeth did
you have a last follow-up and i do and i
just
i'm just curious is in attorney tolle's
experience how many people's auto
insurance covers
this
this type of damage i've never i mean
i'm going to check my policy now but i'm
you know we write a lot of policies here
in new hampshire i'm just wondering how
many auto
policies cover this or is this a
personal liability usually i'm sure
everyone's thinking that as they're
hearing this now as well so that no this
is something a lot of people don't don't
really pay attention to until it happens
to them
dot can get much better numbers for how
the actual
insurance covers everything
most of the cases that come to me are
individuals who don't have insurance or
insurance chose not to cover the plan
for one reason or another whether it's
an action on the individual side or just
the coverage and
extend that far
it's my understanding though that a
majority of the cases are covered by
insurance
thank you representative chase
thank you thank you for taking my
questions
also attorney told so i
a lot of the things that i had questions
on were just
answered that representative macbeth had
but i do want to know
to clarify for me that so say there's an
accident and a bridge is hit or the
guardrail something that makes it unsafe
on the highways for people but the
person who did the damage
doesn't have that money right now so dot
has this in the budget that they will go
out and make these
fixings and then make it deemed safe for
people to ride on the road and then does
the state of new hampshire file a case
against the person who had the accident
or did the damage is that how it works
or
do we wait until
you get the money and then go out and
fix it
so once again this is a good question
for dot just because they have much
better information on their end of
things what i can explain to is my my
understanding and i've kind of worked
through that exact process several times
now where if someone collides with some
part of the highway causing some damage
to it dot will go out as quickly as
possible to go and fix it to get it up
to a usable safe level
uh weather obviously affects that and
the severity of the damage can affect
that
but typically it's as quick as they can
uh
once someone has struck the guardrail
dot will issue out a notice to them
saying oh no you were found that you
damaged this here's the invoice for the
damage that occurred uh because of the
fact that they can't always give the
exact damages that occur due to just how
much
how much stuff they're purchasing at one
time to repair many parts of the highway
at once uh they send out an estimate so
typically d.o.t will dispatch one of its
representatives they'll go and look at
let's just say the guard rail that's
like that
they'll go and measure it and say oh
this guard rail would damage in this way
so we need to replace you know four
posts and we need to
replace this you know
20 foot stretch of the actual guard
system
they will then calculate how much does
that cost to purchase and then send that
estimate out to
the individual who's been found
responsible that individual will be
given several notices uh dot is required
to send out multiple notices some of
these notices uh before it ever comes to
me are required to inform that if no
collection occurs it's going to be sent
over to my office
once dot has been unable to collect from
one of these individuals they then
contact my office we go through make
sure that they've sent out the notices
make sure this individual has been
properly notified that they aren't
liable
and then once it comes to me my own
practice is to reach out to the debtor
myself either by phone or my letter
email whatever correspondence i can make
and to figure out what the situation is
determine what their
capacity is to pay
typically that is sufficient i'm able to
get people entered into some sort of
payment agreement many people just need
an opportunity to pay over time and they
get nervous when they get told they owe
a thousand dollars they think they'll
have to buy their pocket like that
second
um
and typically that's that's as far as
willing to go people make their payments
and then they're all set
up sometimes people want to challenge it
some people like to
push back and make sure that everything
goes through proper relation channels in
which case yes we do file litigation and
then we'll go through that entire
process until the matter was either
resolved or
it's determined that for whatever reason
collection wouldn't be fair
at that point but that that's more in
the litigation area less than
the liability
yes
representative chase
thank you very much so
then there is a budget at dot to make
these changes
uh or not the changes but to to do the
repairs and then they go after they send
an invoice to people
that is my understanding
is that dod can get much better details
on that okay
thank you
representative horrigan
yes i would
i have a question um
i never even thought about this issue
issue before but uh
these guard rail which and these other
things that people run into are
typically replaced uh every every few
decades anyway um you know
what's um so do these are you are using
a depreciated value where you use the
percentage of the
items
uh useful life that's or even used up or
you're trying to charge people for the
full replacement value
of course i can't speak to what dot's
overall practices are once again only a
certain percentage ever reach my office
uh what i can tell you though is many of
the cases that reach my office uh if it
has been an older
guardrail it's something that they were
sometimes even in the process of fixing
when it gets struck
based on my review of the numbers it
does appear that they go on what was the
actual value of the item construct and
not
what would be the cost of the brand new
item to put it in uh ultimately that
does vary i had after that put an
asterisk next to that just because there
are certain items that
while they may have hit and destroyed it
the only way to replace it now is by
getting a more expensive item
uh my what i always jumped through the
example is the end posts for a lot of
these guard rails are very expensive
very specialty items
an old one may have been
you know put in like you said couple
decades ago
it may only be worth a couple hundred
dollars at this point but to replace it
is
much more expensive uh i do want in my
understanding that eot does take that
into consideration and is willing to
work with
anyone who strikes it to figure out what
would be the fair compensation for that
all right thanks
just
had a uh just a sort of a follow-up
question
and that
i and i guess i'm looking for
your
legal opinion more than anything else
and that is you're you're changing the
standard of proof in this particular
case from
having to prove fault to strict
liability
and you testified earlier i think that
this was just
remedial action you consider that to be
remedial
yes i do sir if only for the fact that
the courts have
interpreted this statute to already be a
strict liability standard uh by using
the language i know i'll rejoice he or
she shall be liable to the state for all
damages of the highway
though that does not use the word strict
for a liability definition saying shall
be liable
the state is consistently arguing the
courts have consistently agreed that
that does in tone strict liability our
purpose for adding in the language at
this point is to ensure there's clarity
for any lay person who does read the law
they'll understand oh that is what it is
instead of having to go through and
review
all the case law
are there any other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you
representative mcmahon
oh represent macbeth you had another
question
um no i'm sorry mr chairman i don't have
another question i just have been
notified that a witness you called
earlier is now able to connect if your
um attorney hillman who wanted to
testify on part eight um is available
when it's appropriate to call him he's
changed computers thank you
thank you
and representative horrigan i see your
hand up are you
no i'm good thanks very thanks
and uh
we'll we'll call representative uh
excuse me uh benjamin i guess it's
attorney hillman syracuse hillman
uh yes are you able to hear me we are
okay great thank you for calling me and
i'm i'm sorry i i was on and could hear
you but i couldn't connect uh on the
prior call
um so and i know it's hard enough with
these bills kind of skipping around so i
appreciate your indulgence i'm
testifying in support of section two
i defer substantively to the testimony
of my
colleagues who already testified on that
and i'm also testifying in support of
section 7 the probate administration
distribution upon intestacy and powers
of attorney as well as uniform
disclaimer of
property interests act um i'm an
attorney at shaheen and gordon in
concord and dover where i focus my
practice on probate litigation estate
planning and elder law
i
as others have indicated these bills
passed as standalone bills passed the
senate last year
were not acted upon in the house
and judge david king the administrative
judge of the circuit court reviewed
provided feedback on and supports the
changes to the waiver of administration
um statute i just wanted to be clear he
he did not provide comment on the other
um
portions of of the proposed part
seven
um
i wanna i wanna be brief because i know
others have already testified i know
it's been a long hearing i just wanted
to touch on a couple of things so as
others said the waiver of administration
process it's a process that's been in
new hampshire law since 2002
its applicability has been expanded
several times
and i think the best way to describe it
is essentially an abbreviated probate
process where the legislature has
determined that the full
probate process involving an inventory
an accounting and the posting of a bond
is not necessary
currently it only applies where there's
only a single beneficiary of an estate
and that person is a spouse a child or a
trust and it does not currently apply
where there is more than one beneficiary
or where the sole beneficiary is someone
other than a spouse child or trust such
as a sibling a friend or an unmarried
significant other
and this bill would essentially expand
waiver to cover all estates
where there's either a sole beneficiary
and that beneficiary is administrator or
where there are multiple beneficiaries
and they're all co-administrators or
they all assent to the appointment of
one of them or someone else as
administrator or where it's otherwise
appropriate in the discretion of the
court and in short the concept is for
those estates that are uncontested where
no one where none of the beneficiaries
or interested parties
such as a creditor would be asking the
court to have the full process that it's
not a good use of resources either of
the estate or of the the taxpayers
funding the judiciary to have these
extra court um procedures you know
waiver as i said has been around since
2002 it works very well in the estates
where it applies
and um having it expanded to uncontested
estates um
i i think is you know consistent both
with the direction other states have
gone
um and and would you know i think make
lives easier for um
for folks administering estates in new
hampshire that are uncontested um to be
clear the regular probate process would
remain available and would of course
remain appropriate in contested estates
or were there simply a lack of trust
between beneficiaries
any any beneficiary
you know has the any interested person
has the option to petition for full
administration at any time while the
estate remains open that's in current
law and that's maintained in the bill
and in the states with more than one
beneficiary the simplified process would
not be available unless they all
affirmatively agreed to have it apply um
so those are some safeguards importantly
creditors would retain all the
protections they have under current law
including the six-month creditor claims
period
during which assets can't get
distributed to beneficiaries
that right to seek full administration
and the protections of the insolvent
estate process when
assets are not adequate
to pay
debts
the bill also makes a couple of other
helpful changes it explicitly allows the
court to grant an extension to the
one-year deadline for essentially
closing an estate in a waiver of
administration process under current law
that's not clear
and different judges have taken
different views as to whether or not
they can extend that deadline
and the bill also makes clear how
deadlines would operate if you have an
estate that starts out in the waiver
process and then subsequently becomes
full administration and that's something
else that's not clear under current law
and has sometimes resulted in
inconsistent application
and confusion
uh section three would resolve an
ambiguity in the intestacy statute
without any uh substantive change being
intended
sections four through seven deal with
the uniform power of attorney act which
became law on january 1 2018 and these
amendments are largely to take into
account experience practitioners have
had with the law you know over its first
three years of existence uh um as well
as to update it to reference um to
cross-reference another law the revised
uniform fiduciary access to digital
assets act which um became law in in
june of 2019 after the
power of attorney act had gone into
effect um the year before
um in particular uh
section seven amends the form there's a
statutory form that individuals can use
that to make a valid power of attorney
in new hampshire and in addition to some
clarifying amendments
there are a number of additions to that
form that would allow
individuals to be more specific and have
more choice
about when
and whether they'd authorize gifting to
take place
provisions in a financial power of
attorney allowing an agent to make gifts
or to benefit themselves are essential
in some situations but unfortunately
provide opportunities for abuse in
others so based on experience with the
form
uh the the the folks involved in
drafting you know try to realize the
goal of maximizing flexibility for
individual users of the form while
minimizing the opportunity for abuse by
empowering those who use the form to
make deliberate specific
and if they wish narrow choices you know
as appropriate for their situation
finally
sections nine and ten um are uh were a
separate standalone bill last year um
the
to to update the uniform disclaimer of
property interest act uh new hampshire's
current act um was enacted in 1996 and
became effective january 1 of 97 and has
not been amended since so this act would
update it with the new uniform act
with some changes that are specific to
new hampshire including as i think
someone else pointed out changes
requested by the department of health
and human services to ensure that a
disclaimer
can't be used to impair
uh estate recovery
i think i will i will stop there thank
you for your listening and your
consideration and i'm happy to take any
questions
are there any questions
see none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you for listening
aaron poitras
hello can you hear me we can
okay great
uh good morning chairman gorman
gordon members of the committee
for the record my name is aaron poitras
i'm a laser safety officer for bae
systems electronic systems sector in
nashua new hampshire i'm testifying on
behalf of the company
i'm here to talk on part one of senate
bill 134
uh chairman could i respectfully request
that mr tom bishop and mr david cuzzy
are also activated to testify
and mr tom bishop
david cousy is going to speak on the
amendment that senator carson had
mentioned
in her testimony earlier this morning
so i will get on with my testimony while
we work on that
uh bae system supports part one of
senate bill 134 regarding prohibition of
certain uses of laser pointing devices
we're seeking an amendment to the bill
to make a technical correction which mr
cousy is going to discuss here shortly
we don't have any position on any of the
other parts of this omnibus legislation
by way of background in 2016 a bill was
signed into law prohibiting the shining
of a laser pointing device at an
airplane law enforcement officer law
enforcement vehicle or other persons or
structures
the bill was in response to such laser
pointer incidents in the state and
nationwide the 2016 law included very
limited exceptions which had the
unintentional effect of making some of
today's everyday uses of lasers
potentially illegal from vehicle sensors
to the latest consumer electronics
our company became aware of this issue
with the new hampshire state law about a
year ago
at the time it was too late to seek any
legislative remedy
the reason we approached senator carson
with this issue
is that the law also prohibits some of
the research development and testing
work that aerospace and defense
technology companies like bae systems
conduct with lasers
to be clear bae systems takes every
precaution to legally work around the
unintended prohibitions set forth in the
2016 law until the legislator can
provide a remedy
in addition we are not aware of any law
enforcement entity interpreting and
enforcing the statute beyond the intent
of the law as it is currently
however we do believe appropriate
exemptions should be placed in the
statute to clarify lawful uses while
ensuring that malicious use of lasers
and laser pointers remains prohibited
i'd like to thank the department of
safety transportation
and fish and game for their willingness
to provide feedback to us as we worked
to provide a solution for legislators to
consider
i respectfully request that the
committee recommends ought to pass with
the amendment we're seeking on part one
of senate bill 134
thank you for your time and your
consideration happy to take any
questions that you might have
thank you why don't we hear from uh
uh mr kazzy and mr bishop and then
we can ask questions of all three so
thank you mr chairman uh again uh for
the record my name is david cuzzy with
prospect hill strategies here in concord
uh on behalf here today of va systems of
course um very quickly regarding the
amendment and members of the committee i
did send over
late friday all of the written materials
a letter from
ba systems a one-page overview of the
the bill itself uh and then a
uh and then a uh just a quick half a
page or so on the amendment uh as well
as miss poitras's testimony so you
should have all that i'm happy to resend
as necessary regarding the amendment uh
this is just a technical amendment and
i'm certainly not speaking for d.o.t but
uh they've indicated that they're
that they're very comfortable with the
amendment uh back in
when the original bill
banning the shining of lasers uh laser
pointers at aircraft or uh the other uh
structures and so on that you've heard
already
when that became law they needed to in
order to affect that prohibition they
needed to
amend
two chapters of
new hampshire rsas the first was 631
uh and
and i don't mean to oversimplify uh but
uh that that for the point of this
um
this issue this prohibition deals with
the
items that are on the ground uh so the
buildings
people and airplanes
that may not be underway
rsa422 that is the the aeronautics act
and so in order to make sure that the
prohibition was extended to planes while
in flight which i believe the legal
definition is um taxiing uh takeoff
landing and actually you know in flight
uh the the prohibition had to be written
there as well unfortunately just due to
a
in oversight as this was moving through
the senate uh the bill before you part
one
did not um did not update rsa 422
as it did rsa 631 so it didn't update
to make sure that
the prohibition extended to using drones
uh
right now in theory someone could use a
laser pointer mounted on a drone and
shine that at a plane and that in theory
would not be
a violation of new hampshire law so this
updates that and then also
points back to
what the bill is proposing to carve out
four exceptions um to the use of laser
pointers that would
that would be in in rsa 631
so um i i hope i hope i'm not uh making
this more confusing
but again it was just to make sure that
we were applying the uh the updates and
uh the exclusions uh
equally um
in into both statutes as the original
law did and as uh and as was intended as
this bill was moving through the through
the senate uh and i'm happy to
to answer any questions uh as
appropriate uh thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee
thank you annie uh and mr bishop did you
wish to testify as well
mr chairman thank you for your time i'm
here in support of aaron and i'll defer
to her testimony although i'm happy to
answer questions
thank you and are there any questions
for
ms poydras mr cousy or mr bishop
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
the next person to testify
would be ken norton
if he's still here
good morning chairman gordon and members
of the committee
my name is ken norton and i'm the
executive director of nami new hampshire
the national alliance on mental illness
i'm also have family members with mental
illness and co-occurring substance use
disorders
i've by way of background i've served as
a subject matter expert for the
in mental health and suicide prevention
for the department of defense the
veterans administration and the federal
substance abuse and mental health
services administration
i also currently serve on the governor's
commission on courts and corrections and
served on governor sununu's law
enforcement accountability community and
transparency commission
and i've provided training to law
enforcement off and on for four decades
nami new hampshire currently provides 16
hours of mental health training to all
full-time
recruits coming through the police
academy and on behalf of nami new
hampshire i'm here to speak in favor of
section 9 of senate bill 134 regarding
mental health intervention training
the background on this is that a 2016
review and report by the new hampshire
department of justice on
officer-involved shootings
indicated that 45 of those shootings in
new hampshire involved the person with
known mental illness and this is
considerably higher than the national
average of about 25 percent
you heard mention of two
by senator geider earlier i would also
mention the recently issued report
of the killing of a naked unarmed man
and thornton
last october
and nami new hampshire has been engaged
in ongoing conversations about
responding to individuals in a mental
health crisis and use of deadly force
with a number of different folks
a bunch of conversations with former
attorney general mcdonald and other
members of the attorney general's office
and this bill directly follows those
conversations which kind of ended
abruptly last february
when um covet hit but also with
commissioner quinn from the new
hampshire department of safety his
predecessor commissioner barthelms
and other policy leaders including my
senator senator geider who i'd like to
thank for sponsoring this
for the past three years nami new
hampshire has been
providing
crisis intervention team training which
is an international model of 40-hour
training
which includes de-escalation
strategies communication strategies
um and
to the department of safety
new hampshire state police and
first responders and
ems and fire as well
and it
um
the
in 2016 the president
after a number of shootings in the u.s
convened a task force which issued a
report on 21st century policing and
their report has served as a blueprint
for reforming
law enforcement in many communities in
implementing police reform and one of
the recommendations of that report is
that the cit training should be provided
to every law enforcement officer
in the country
nami new hampshire has a certified cit
training facilitator we coordinate over
20 subject matter experts as faculty
including chief goldstein who you heard
from earlier um
and uh and the other part to the
training in
in addition to those de-escalation
strategies and communications pieces
extensive playing
with real life scenarios most of the
actors and i put that in quote are
people that have mental illness or their
family members who have
personally experienced the mental health
crisis requiring law enforcement
response and nami new hampshire has
trained in the to serve in these roles
of cit
training the other really key part of
this
training is that it focuses on
officers own wellness and resilience and
what mental health supports are
available to them
rates of suicide among law enforcement
are significantly higher than the
general population as are rates of
depression and um and ptsd and sadly
more law enforcement officers die by
suicide than in the line of duty and new
hampshire has certainly experienced
several of these tragic
deaths in the past few years
the demand for this type of training is
very high and uh and when we offer it um
we typically uh run out of space 25 to
30 people within several hours and and
have a waiting list and as you heard
senator goddess say this training this
grant that we've been operating under is
due to to run out um and uh and
therefore we've submitted this bill so i
would ask for your support for section
nine and vote senate bill 134 is ought
to pass and i'm happy to answer
any questions you have thanks for your
time chase
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you mr norton for taking my question
you answered some of them but i want to
make sure i got my hand up so the
funding right now um the senator said is
through
a
it's through the federal funding and
then it trickles down into the state
and is you have a wait list you said 25
to 30 people who sign up at a time how
often are these trainings given
and how long is the training and then do
you follow up with the officers like do
they have to do it in five years or
how is it regulated
thank you representative chase those are
great questions so the the current uh
grant was a three-year grant from the
substance about substance abuse and
mental health services administration it
expires on september 30th
and um
the training itself is 40 hours long
and the
um
there is a recertification process
that's an additional eight-hour training
i think that that's once every three
years
but that could be a training in any area
relative to mental health and training
offered by
police standards and training there was
one other question in there i think that
i missed
um
i oh i just are the officers certified
when they do that like if would you had
more funds would you be able to do more
than 25 or 30 officers at a time
yeah the um so the the the training we
had it the last formal live training we
had prior to the pandemic actually ended
on
march 13th which i think was the day
that the president declared the state of
emergency
it was a training for 25 or 30. we had
52 people in that training
but the the challenge is that because of
the intensive role model i'm role
playing aspect to the training that we
have to limit you know in terms of so
that people are actually getting that
first-hand practice in terms of role
modeling but um we've been offering it
um about three times a year we have
offered it a couple times since the
pandemic socially distanced
um and we are going to be offering it
again in hopefully in june july and
august of this year one of the other
challenges with that is that um you know
with 20 different faculty members it's
it places a significant burden on them
many of them are volunteers but
but we do rely on their expertise
okay follow up yes you may
thank you i'm sorry so um
shoot no i
is this going to be become a requirement
for officers in
every town or is this just going to be
something that is a volunteer
and do you have also is there follow-up
training or help for the officers as far
as
psychologically you know if they're in
distress themselves with this
yes again thank you those are great
questions um no we
while it was recommended in the in the
president's 21st century
um
policing report that it does be a
requirement we are not making it a
requirement but we definitely want to
increase
the availability of the number of
officers in new hampshire that are
trained
there are some departments that have uh
that have um offered it from time to
time on their own but it's been very
inconsistent
um and this would make it more
consistent and relative to the um
wellness of police officers there's been
a great deal of activity
that's that's occurred relative to that
most notably through state police and
their standing up a peer support program
where they train
law enforcement officers to serve as
peers to each other
to assist so that people know who they
can go to uh chief goldstein had also
mentioned the granite state critical
incident stress debriefing team which
has been around for a while which which
provides supports and certainly there is
um you know employee assistance programs
that are offered through
through most departments i think the
bigger challenge with this is changing
the culture around um for our first
responders to that they recognize that
their own personal needs for maintaining
their mental health and their
vulnerabilities and their willingness to
uh to seek help and recognize um and
support each other in doing that
terrific thank you very much
representative silvia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question mr norton um
i may have missed something along the
way but so forgive me if i i'm asking
something that's already been spoken of
um
you talk about uh
your training and
is this a separate
um
instruction from the standard police
training
yes thank you for your question
currently
police officers going through the
the academy receive
i think it's 500
odd hours of instructional training of
that 16 hours of it are in uh in mental
health um but those numbers have changed
quite a bit over the years so
for instance and i'm just i'm taking a
guess because uh over 40 years it's a
bit of a blur but let's say 20 years ago
that requirement was four hours of
mental health training
and then uh somewhere in there that um
you know maybe 12 years ago that changed
to a doubled up to eight hours of
officers going through the academy um
and then a few years back maybe six
years ago it doubled up to 16. so that
means some of those some of our older
officers have only had four hours of
mental health training um unless they've
sought it out before so this would be an
opportunity to
um to increase the the base both for you
know for newer officers but for older
officers uh in the field as well
so if i can follow up mr chairman you
can
um so
i guess part of what i'm trying to get
clear is is this part of the academy or
is this a training that's done by nami
or some other group
thanks for your question the the bill is
written so that the funding would go to
the academy
and the academy
could then
contract for that
training or they could provide it
themselves currently under the current
grant nami
wrote the grant and is providing the
training
but the bill is written so that it would
go to the academy and while obviously as
uh as a representative of nami i would
hope that we would have the opportunity
to
uh to provide that training our goal is
to really ensure that this training
continues in the state
um whoever is providing it
thank you and one more follow-up mr
chairman sure certainly
so as far as adami
doing training um
how familiar are you with the rest of
the training that uh cadets get in the
academy uh i i guess i'm trying to
to determine if there are conflicting
things taught on one side of the program
and then another uh is there is there a
prob any problem with um cross-training
or
conflicting training
i'm sorry representative sylvia i
couldn't quite hear the last part of
your sentence
i'm trying to determine whether there is
an issue with uh training that
is the normal part of the academy that
might be in conflict with what training
you or nami or the mental health side of
things would be teaching
um thank you for your question i mean i
i don't want to speak for director
skipper and the academy but i will
certainly say that he's been very
supportive of the training that
that nami does and has been supportive
of this uh
this effort to uh move uh this part of
senate bill 134 forward and he's been
involved in the conversations that we've
had uh relative to this and he's very
familiar with um with crisis
intervention team training and i will
just say that we
that we are not calling it um crisis
intervention team training in this build
just for proprietary reasons
so uh this came out of some of the
conversations that we had with uh then
attorney general mcdonald the suggestion
was that we just call it mental health
intervention training
thank you
representative horrigan
um yes thank you very much mr chair this
is some
this part exists in addition to the uh
budget bills which are wending their way
to the senate so what is the uh
significance of the fact that we're
having this in addition to
whatever is appropriate in the budget to
the uh
for uh for these programs aside from i
guess
extra money turns up uh the fiscal
committee can simply uh authorize if
authorization of having this in addition
to the budget
thank you for your question um
representative horgan
um i'm not really clear i will just say
that when we had conversations with the
governor's office that the governor's
office
suggested that we
put it forward as a separate bill
and
i believe that the governor also did
include it in
in his budget
okay thanks
representative simpson
hello thank you mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question mr norton um
i hope that i didn't miss this earlier
but i was just wondering if this if this
funding would open up um the possibility
of matching grants to from the federal
um department of justice for training in
mental health interventions
thank you for your question we are
always monitoring um the possibility of
of additional training and applying for
uh for those types of grants when they
become available
and
yeah i suppose you know i mean it would
depend on the on the type of grant
in terms of whether it could be matching
funds or or not
all set
any other questions from mr norton
see none thank you very much for your
testimony today
thank you all
marie mullen
hello good morning mr chair and members
of the committee good morning
my name is marie mullen i'm the director
of finance at the department of
transportation
and i'm here to in support of part four
of the bill relative to civil liability
and damage to the highways
assistant attorney general zachary toll
testified a short time ago
and
i wanted to just clarify the department
had wanted to
bring this forward
because of concerns raised by the ag's
office
questioning whether we are authorized to
use estimated costs for pending damage
damage claims
without authorization to use estimated
costs the like the state will likely
fail to collect thousands of damages
owed to the state
this provision would allow d.o.t to use
estimates or actual costs for
reimbursement of the damage
the department uses estimated costs and
many damage claims as the actual costs
are not known
for the work
to be performed and there can be many
reasons for this one of those is winter
much of this damage can occur during the
winter
we cannot make
those repairs during winter the ground's
frozen you may have
snow banks along the side of the road so
we there may be a time before we can
make those
um repairs and we'll know what the
actual costs are
and the same thing with timing of
projects and so if the department waits
until it has actual costs the statute of
limitations may expire in many cases and
we wouldn't be able to collect for the
damage that has occurred
the amendment that senator carson
referenced to pursue pending claims
those have been on hold for the past
year year and a half
we have not been
submitting claims to the attorney
general's office that we have been able
unable to collect on because we are
using estimates
and we do not and it was under the we
are under the impression that we will
not be able to pursue those unless we
have actual costs so we have not been
providing these pending live liabilities
to the to the ag's office to collect on
so without this cemented language we
wouldn't be able to pursue you know
several hundred thousand dollars of
claims to for damage to state property
um so the inclusion of these pending
claims is not creating liability but
it's
allowing us to use estimates
for these claims where people have
determined to be liable already
um and there were some questions earlier
about funding in the budget
the funding for these repairs is not in
our budget we rely on the revenue we
bring in to be able to make these
repairs
and
you know when dot personnel have to make
these repairs they are taken away from
other duties and projects um to work on
these these type of items
um and i know there were some other
questions uh related to whether
insurance covers this and the answer is
yes it is damage to property and is
included on folks insurance claims
so um
in fiscal year 20 we had 215
damage claims that came through the
department for damage to the highways
around the state
about 157 or 73 percent had insurance
and 58 or 27 percent did not have
insurance so
just as a representation there and i
know there were questions about um you
know the costs and the majority the
majority of the claims in that year
about 67 were less than three thousand
dollars
and 40 to 41 percent were less than a
thousand dollars so
these are not huge claims we don't you
know we aren't trying to get uh the
money back for the full guard rail as
attorney general um toll was discussing
we will look at only the section that is
damaged and
you know our billing for
time labor and materials
for that to repair that damage
so i'd like to thank you for your
consideration and i'll i'm happy to
answer any questions regarding this this
bill and amendment
representative horrigan
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much mrs mullen
and actually i apologize i asked a
question of the ag's office which was
about depreciation and i see now that
flatly says
such costs shall not be reduced for
depreciation so
why is it uh why is it done that way
since um none of these
pictures on the side of the highway last
forever you have a
scheduled uh
you replace them every so often uh often
anyway so like why
i mean
why if somebody say destroys a section
of guardrail that say was like 19 years
old and going to be placed in here why
are they paying for 100 of the
replacement costs instead of uh
five percent since it would have
theoretically had been replaced uh
a year later even nobody had had
destroyed it so
thank you
and you ever run the problems with
insurance companies when you
try to uh
try to and would you ever run the props
insurance companies if you try to
replace that
without accounting for depreciation
yeah the the law
previously to to this request has said
that includes replacement costs of
productive barriers when maintained and
blah blah so it is always said that we
could do replacement costs um and
understandably these assets last a long
time so
um you know generally they're they're
hit quite frequently so
generally the depreciation
it hasn't really gone to that level yet
we're not at 20 or 30 or 40 years some
of these assets can last
40 50 years
so we're not really
depreciating that but we need to factor
in the replacement costs to the highway
highway system uh the highway and
turnpike funds
uh the highway fund is
not very uh
liquid at
at this time and so to be able to
recover the cost to replace and repair
those
vital safety um you know whether it's
guardrail whether it's lighting we have
light posts that are hitting knocked
over
signs those are all
vital safety
components of the highway system that
need to be replaced to ensure the safety
of the traveling public
okay thanks
representative macbeth
thank you mr chair and thank you miss
mullen
um i'm wondering i
previously read there have been some
questions regarding what states other
states perhaps um have this liability
and i've found two that do do
but they also limit the liability the
civil liability to um whether it was
negligence on the drivers or illegal
operations say an overweight truck or
the damage was done by something like
that
in new hampshire are is is the previous
law is the current law or does this law
change or
how does it define who is liable is
strict liability everybody regardless of
whether it was an accident
um i would defer to the attorney
general's office on that question i'm
sorry i'm not i am not um
you know familiar with the legal um
interpretation of these items um i do
know that
um you know we
to determine the liability we do have
police reports we we get the police
reports we
identify
that information before we determine any
the person that's liable for the damage
but i'm not
you know can't really speak to the
strict liability versus
other requirements
thank you you're correct my my question
was misplaced thank you
any other questions for miss mullen
i i
i just
i asked the question earlier tonight uh
and that's
my understanding was that this was in
the budget or in the budget bills at one
point in time or asked to be amended to
the budget
process but wasn't amended is that
correct
um that's correct we have it in house
bill 2 in the budget bill
and i believe representative umberger
had contacted
your committee or yourself for input
into that and i think based on your
your the committee's recommendation they
removed the section on the retrospective
and that's why we wanted to come to you
here and explain
uh you know the the purpose of it and
that you know we weren't adding people
who are liable that we're just trying to
it's related to the estimated versus
actual cost so these folks have already
been determined to be liable
but if we can't use estimated costs then
we will not be able to collect anything
from these folks for the damage that has
occurred
so
you know we're not trying to create
additional liability so we wanted to
come here and explain it with with a
potential amendment here
so just so i understand it's already in
house bill 2 with the exception of the
part making it retroactive
that is correct
and
and in terms of making it retroactive
the you'll be able to use the estimates
in the future just not on the
pending cases that's correct
thank you
freddie macbeth did you have another
question or is
attorney macbeth do you have a
no any other questions
okay thank you very much for your
testimony today
thank you very much
peter early
good morning
thank you to the uh committee my name is
peter earley i'm a resident of windham
um i'm uh here to uh comment on section
five of the bill um i am a practitioner
of structured settlements uh i've been
for
15 years and i also am speaking on
behalf of the national instruction
settlements trade association which i
sit on the board of directors
as you may know structured settlements
help provide
people
financial recovery after a loss with
secure guaranteed tax-free income
and we are aware that circumstances
change in people's lives and there may
be a need for them to
access a secondary market transaction
and we are in support of the structured
settlement protection act
that is included in this bill we feel
that it's the best way for people to
have uh the consumer protections they
need when they are required to enter
into that type of transaction
um and uh on behalf of myself and the
national structure settlements trade
association we're just speaking in
support of that today and uh i'll be
brief i know this has gone on a long
time one thing i'll mention i know
senator carson mentioned at the outset i
believe mr dear did as well uh new
hampshire is the only state that does
not have a structured settlement
protection act and we feel this would be
a a very good measure so i'm happy to
answer any questions
any questions for mr earley
see none thank you for your brief
testimony thank you
canard jones
morning mr jones hello can you hear me
we can
great thank you chairman and thank you
to the committee uh my name is crenar
jones i am here on behalf of uh notarize
where i serve as the urban affairs
analyst
i am here in support of part two of
senate bill 134
uh more specifically the revised uniform
uh law on editorial acts
piece to the bill
notarize is a digital trust provider a
platform that integrates technology with
live human interaction to establish
identities we offer digital identity
proofing and authentication services
including market leading notary public
platform to allow any person or
organization to get their documents
notarized online 24 7.
our mission is to help people execute
the most important transactions of their
lives and make notarizations more
convenient and secure through enhanced
authentications integrity preserving
protocols which create non-reputable
records access to digital services is
more important than ever and at notarize
we applaud the efforts to ensure remote
online notarization works for not only
consumers but also attorneys notaries in
the industries of new hampshire we want
to thank the house committee on
judiciary for taking the time to hear
public testimony for senate bill 134
which if enacted would in part allow for
a permanent run we support the remote
online notarization component of senate
bill 134 in its current form and in
closing we want to thank again
senator carson for bringing forth this
bill and the committee for taking my
testimony into consideration thank you
are there any questions for
mr jones
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you for being brief this morning
thank you
we have right now we have six more
witnesses
most of whom said they needed either two
minutes or one minute so
we'll see if we can get these are all
people who signed up in
advance jay mckay
can you hear me
great thank you uh
give me one second here
you asked for two minutes yep
uh
thank you mr chairman thank you members
of the house appreciate me for allowing
me to testify my name is jay mackey and
i am the administrator of
classifications and client records for
the new hampshire department of
corrections i'm speaking on behalf of
the doc in support of section 3 of
senate bill 134 relative to
incarceration of a suspended sentence
as representative shapiro stated this
bill does not change when an individual
will be eligible to be released
according to rsa 650 120 but changes the
time in which they are allowed to
petition the court
so allowing residents to apply for their
suspension of their sentence 12 months
prior to their two-thirds date will
allow for these residents to participate
in re-entry programs and services prior
to their release the way the current law
is they cannot apply until they reach
their two-thirds date which the process
being as soon as they get the suspension
granted by the court they are
immediately parole eligible they'll have
a parole hearing within 30 days and if
they come up with a housing plan they
could be released within a month or two
this would allow them to begin
programming
you know back into the community getting
ties in the community going through our
minimum security programs as well as
work release as most of these people
will have been incarcerated for at least
three four years and will need some form
of reentry services and get connections
set up in the community prior to their
release
excuse me
a lot of these people will not be able
to get into their
recommended or required intensive
programming until they're two years from
their minimum
so most of the times they'll go in front
of court they will not have completed
their sex offender treatment or their
residential substance abuse treatment
yet
but that would be on the court to decide
whether or not they could still suspend
the sentence so they can get into those
programs earlier um that's not really a
logistical issue for us
on that end it's more of a court's
decision for that
um so yes as i said as representative
shapiro mentioned we we are in support
of this bill and i welcome any questions
anyone has on our processes and
programming and and so forth
questions from mr mckee
yes representative langley
representative langley have to unmute
thank you mr chair um and thank you mr
mcgee for taking my question am i clear
to understand that a parole a potential
parolee can apply for this um waiver but
won't be able to access necessarily the
appropriate
programs
um once they've received a positive um a
review and they've been given granted
this waiver
is that what you said
uh thank you for the question um i might
have went a little too quickly for that
i apologize
once uh so in the current rsa they apply
for the two-thirds
at their two-thirds date so their
sentence the minimum sentence is
immediately suspended which means they
are actually all eligible at that time
they get into their programming or have
already done their programming
if they are allowed to apply 12 months
in advance
once the court grants it we still have
that you know anywhere from nine to 12
months after all the court hearings to
start preparing for their release and if
they are required to continue with some
form of programming they will be able to
get into that a lot faster than they
would have if the sentence had not been
suspended
um because normally in these intensive
programs they need to do it somewhere
closer to their actual release date so
they can utilize the skills they've
learned
to
uh use while they're reprogramming and
going out into the community so if they
do it too far
ahead of their release date they may
have to have some sort some form of
refresher course or something like that
um to take before they're actually
allowed to go back out in the community
thank you follow up mr chair yes you may
um do you anticipate that you might have
a capacity issue at any point as a
result of this
uh
meaning like uh over overcapacity at the
moment right exactly uh well we are not
over capacity since kobit we've gone
down probably on at least at the state
prison for men we're about 100 anywhere
from 100 around 150
lower our head count's about 150
residents lower than it was before covid
up at our facility in berlin we're about
150 residents lower than we were before
covid
um a lot of that has to do with the
suspension of the court processes and
the trials and and
such but we also expedited our
administrative home confinement process
where we lowered our standards for those
individuals to go out on electronic
monitoring we just sped up the process
so it didn't take two to three months to
get somebody else on there so the people
that are actually incarcerated behind
the walls is less than we had prior to
covet
thank you thank you mr chu
any other questions for mr mckay
no thank you for your testimony today
thank you
stephen bauer
wellness power
sorry about them good morning good
morning mr chairman and members of the
committee my name's steve bauer i'm the
executive director of the mortgage
bankers and brokers association of new
hampshire
testifying and support on part two
we are the organizing member of the task
force that met last summer and fall
and through the process we answered
everybody's
questions
their concerns with answers
we put together a draft bill
and that was also a unanimous consent to
move forward
to where we are right now
um just want everybody to know that the
remote online notarization will not
replace a traditional notary or
electronic in-person notary it's another
tool in the toolbox that provides
notaries the legal framework to
modernize the practices
to meet the evolving needs of businesses
and consumers
so mortgage bankers and brokers
association supports this bill and hopes
that the committee will also support and
move forward thank you
any questions
mr power
say none thank you for your testimony
thank you for keeping it brief
marissa chase
good morning members of the committee
for the record my name is marissa chase
i'm the executive director of the new
hampshire association for justice which
is the trade association of about 400
attorneys statewide primarily focusing
on plaintiff's issues i'm here today to
speak in support of sections five and
six five the structured settlement
protection act and we thank um
representatives burch and gordon for
bringing forth an amendment to address
some concerns that the new hampshire
judicial branch had
um i just want to
briefly
mentioned that
the structured settlement trade
protection act so when you think of a
structured settlement um that's put
together by folks like peter earley who
work at wrangler associates part of the
structured settlement trade association
on behalf of a client of one of our
members an attorney who's been injured
so the structured settlement trade
association folks go and get the best
deal they can for a tax-free annuity
payment to man you know for someone's
payment after they have been
um injured
and
sometimes um you know due to life
circumstance or whatever may happen an
individual later on may decide that they
want to
sell their structured settlement to an
entity represented by the national
um association of settlement purchasers
so all of these folks as well as the
judicial branch are on board with the
language reflected in representative
birch's and representative gordon's
amendment to section 5.
that is no easy feat when you think of
the odds that all these groups are
usually
at
so we just want to thank
you all for your work and letting us
um kind of hammer that out and then
section six the collaborative law act
while the collaborative law alliance is
its own organization many nha members
are crossover members of the
collaborative law alliance and they are
very much in support representative
gordon earlier you had asked
if this was a bill that had been brought
up before
after the collaborative law alliance
painstakingly as representative macbeth
knows
came up with language to put some
parameters on the practice of
collaborative law that is currently
happening again voluntarily
um it was only brought up for the first
time last session so this says this
isn't an issue that's been you know
continuously brought up and failed or i
just wanted to clarify um
for your mind with your question earlier
representative
so i'm happy to take any questions and
um hope i kept it brief enough
are there any questions from this chase
see none thank you for your testimony
thank you
henry vayu
it's there
if you're there henry raise your hand
ryan hale
good afternoon uh chairman boarding can
you hear me weekend
excellent excellent well i hope to win
the award for brevity this afternoon now
um for the record uh my name is ryan
hale i'm vice president government
relations for the new hampshire bankers
association we represent 38 member banks
which employ roughly 6000 employees here
in the state of new hampshire
as a sponsor had mentioned uh we were
part of the task force uh or the
stakeholder group that worked on
part
two of senate bill 134 um and
we appreciate being invited to the table
um and therefore we're here to voice our
support of uh part two which deals with
the remote um online notarization
and with that i will end my testimony
and happy to take any questions
committee members may have
thank you for your very brief testimony
is there are there any questions
mr hale
seeing none
thank you you're welcome thank you
the last person who pre-registered to
speak today is carol willoughby
hello
good morning
well good afternoon
uh thank you chairman gordon vice
chairman mclean members of the committee
my name is carol willoughby i am a
dually licensed attorney in new
hampshire and employed by first american
title insurance company we're a leading
provider of real estate settlement
services and certainly a major consumer
of notary services i'm also a licensed i
think i already said that sorry
i was a member of the stakeholder group
and was involved in the drafting of
section two of senate bill 134 i did
provide written testimony but i'll focus
on just two key points here
first section two
quite simply creates an additional
method of performing notarial services
remotely
it doesn't take away other provisos
we've been fortunate to have the use of
governor sununu's emergency order
throughout the pandemic but our citizens
quite frankly need a more robust and
permanent solution
our notaries perform a variety of
important services which serve as a
foundation to the rebuy to the
reliability of our legal documents our
legal system our real estate documents
the elements of a strong safe remote
online notarization law do exist in
section 2 of senate bill 134
without that face-to-face in-person
interaction we still need to verify
certain things so how do we do that we
use enhanced identification protocols we
use a robust audit trail and we use
secure technology
both
ron technology platforms that are
available and section 2 of the bill use
all of these things enhanced id
protocols
analysis of the signers identification
credentials performed
they also use dynamic multi-factor
authentication based on public and
private data sources
that use objective database questions
and both require an electronic record of
the notarial act both require the use of
tamper evident technology
and the notarial act itself is
undertaken via secure online
communication technology
as of the current date 33 states have
enacted full remote online notarization
four of those since the hearing in the
senate on this very bill
13 additional states including new
hampshire have permanent run legislation
pending and there are additional states
where we believe there are stakeholder
activities happening to brink bring
remote online notarization legislation
in
without a a robust notarization law new
hampshire citizens are at a clear
disadvantage
and thank you i'd be happy to answer any
questions that you may have
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for mrs attorney
willoughby
yes attorney macbeth
thank you uh mr chairman
um and thank you ms willoughby for
taking my i just wanna would you believe
that i think it's amazing really that
you've gotten so many stakeholders
together
um
to create this flexible very significant
but um i think many of the members know
how difficult it is to get any attorneys
to
you know agree i'm sure there's still
some that aren't
quite agreed but anyway i appreciate
your efforts thank you
well you're very welcome and i take no
credit for getting the stakeholders
together but i was fortunate enough to
be invited to join thank you
any other questions
thank you for your testimony today
thank you sir
at this point in time that's all the
people who pre-registered to speak today
i'm just going to ask anyone who's
in the attendance in the audience here
today
if they are interested in speaking if
they could just raise your hand
so i can get an idea of how many
witnesses we have and whether it be
appropriate to break for lunch or to
hear whoever wants to speak
and
we have one
one person wants to speak again
apparently
two
three
four
five six
if uh
we have six people
and they're willing to keep their
testimony brief i think we could
probably finish up without having to
take a lunch break
and so jack kelly
thank you mr chairman my name is jack
kelly i'm here on behalf of the national
association of settlement purchase i
apologize to you and the members of the
committee uh i had registered and for
some reason i received a confirmation
but it
seems to have had some sort of glitch
and i will be brief
uh we urge you to uh adopt the
provisions outlined in the new hampshire
structure settlement provisions in
section five
the only thing i would ask that you
understand everybody is brought to your
attention my colleagues uh mr dean uh mr
early and miss chase
uh the structured settlement protection
act that you have before you uh requires
a judicial review of a uh of
a purchase that is required by federal
law
uh uh that was adopted in 2002 when the
victims bill for 9 11 uh was passed in
congress and it said congress said uh
that in adopting this provision that in
order to ensure that there is no excise
tax penalty in the transaction a 40 tax
penalty uh that it requires a judicial
review and showing that it's in the best
interest
49 states and the district of columbia
have this law the only state in the
united states that hasn't adopted it yet
since its
requirements back in 2002
is new hampshire and this would ensure
that
new hampshire citizens are governed by
new hampshire law instead of being
governed by the laws of other states
that the courts would have to rely on uh
in reviewing the transfer
i i thank you for your time and effort i
know you're busy and i i will only take
time if you have a question for me
yes representative macbeth
i just hadn't lowered my hand i
apologize
okay
any other questions
seeing none thank you mr kelly for your
testimony thank you mr chairman and
member of the committee
next
person
would be
joseph
with ms caves
uh yes thank you um
can you can everyone hear me we can
okay thank you for taking my testimony
chair and members of this committee my
name is joseph scott and i will be
representing the american civil
liberties union of new hampshire in
support of section 3 of this omnibus
bill
i just wanted to just briefly just talk
about the suspended sentence portion uh
i am someone who has actually utilized
um this process and i can tell you that
uh it is a very long process and
to have a successful re-entry that's
going to require preparation i was the
one who negotiated with the doc
the bill's language the amendment to
bring it down to 12 months where it had
originally been 18
and that was over the concerns that we
did here earlier as well as due to the
fact that there wanted to be a time
period so that um
individuals
wouldn't be tempted to to slip back in
behavior um while they had that 18 month
process so
we came to agreement on that um i am
happy to answer any questions that you
may have about this bill and the process
for which a person goes through using it
any questions for mrs
thank you for your testimony today
steve
zamanick
hi could you hear me
we can all right um i'm testifying again
uh
about uh part one which is uh regarding
the laser pointing devices and my
concern with um the the
laser pointing devices uh the way it is
written that it might be overly vague
and it might um
be used in a way that uh
there's uh
hundreds of legitimate use of lasers
that
aren't covered in the exemption of that
bill and i believe that the bill
uh is trying to stop people from shining
at people's eyes and becoming disruptive
and stuff like that um but my concern is
that uh the law is not is the the law is
written or the bill as written is too
vague
and
um in the current bill is also vague and
one of the concerns i have is the use of
lasers for that
for protests and stuff like that with
laser projectors
um because
as written
it shows the um
as the bill is written it says
structures occupied structures and there
have been protests where people have
shined a laser projector
to project messages onto the wall
and
i think that a simple way of solving
this would be
to add language that says the um
uh
must have like malicious intent of or
could blind somebody because as written
it could be used to squash uh first
amendment
um
protected speech
thank you that's all
any questions
seeing them thank you for your testimony
and susan cragan
hello can you hear me this is susan
craig
okay um
good morning er good afternoon mr
chairman and members of the committee
i signed up late but i would like to
register my opposition
to
part 10 of sb 134
i am the merrimack county register of
deeds and also a former senior
investigator with the fdic division of
liquidations working for the fraud
division
um
i'm
testifying
in particular
against 478 a 3 2
the requirement that the registries of
deeds
accept electronic signatures and the
definition used of electronic signatures
the definition is very broad
it was brought forward from legislative
federal legislation first signed in 2000
or 200 2000 by bill clinton
and
the fdic
considered that legislation
dangerous enough so that imposed its own
definition of electronic signature
uh later that year
and
excuse me
electronic signatures um
have the capacity
to be used in um
in bank fraud and what i'm concerned
about mostly
is the last financial crisis that we
went through
um i read the report
from the financial crisis inquiry
commission
and
um
i'd just like to quote one paragraph of
it um a couple of paragraphs are quoted
in the written testimony i
i submitted
um
mers mers the system by which most loans
are bought and sold had questionable
signatures on assignments and affidavits
attesting to the ownership
of the note and mortgage and
questionable notary stamps on
assignments
a robo signer
signed
and sometimes back dated hundreds of
affidavits claiming personal knowledge
of facts
about mortgage they did not actually
know to be true
one such robo signer jeffrey steffen of
gmac said he signed a hundred thousand
affidavits in a month went roughly one
per minute in a forty hour work week
making it highly unlikely that he
verified payment histories
in each individual case of foreclosure
why is that important
because the person signing
affixed his actual signature and
therefore did not have what is called
plausible deniability that was his wet
signature he could not deny it and he
was held accountable for it
but this bill as it stands would allow
all types of these signatures on
anything formed with the intent to
authenticate that could mean names
filled in by computers on massive
amounts of documentation
existing new hampshire law governing
electronic signatures does not help us
it says that parties must agree on the
form of the electronic signatures well
the deeds offices are not parties to the
agreement
the parties to a mortgage transaction
are a financial institution and an
individual
the agreement on electronic signatures
probably in the fine print that the
individual must sign which he will do
without reading or understanding it
we need to think this legislation
through and make sure that e-signatures
are what we want them to be that they
protect not only our economy but our
people especially especially those most
vulnerable to exploitation and that they
hold signers personally accountable
for this reason i oppose the legislation
in its present form and i oppose it on
behalf of the merrimack county registry
of deeds
any questions
are there any questions from ms gregan
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you
and i think that concludes uh uh the
testimony that we're going to receive
today i would i would add one thing i i
just got an amendment back which i put
in yesterday and
which i haven't distributed but i will
distribute out to everyone today but
i
i heard yesterday
that a bill which came out of the house
out of our committee a house bill which
was house bill 540 and you may recall
that was the bill that was sponsored by
representative chase
was heard by the senate
and in the senate
there were 82 people who
signed up in support and zero people who
signed up against
our committee voted it out 21 to nothing
and it was passed on the consent
calendar
but over in the house
it apparently was voted on uh this last
week
three to two to re re-refer it
and i was thinking potentially of
of adding that on as an amendment to uh
to senate bill 130 the content of that
bill on to
senate bill 134 so
uh but i wouldn't do that unless the
committee thought that that was
something that you wanted to do but i
will offer that as an amendment at some
point in time
yes yes yes
okay
and
in any event is there anything else any
other business that we need to address
today we do have another hearing uh
schedule for next week and what i've
tried to do is
schedule it so that uh the next two
weeks we'll have hearings in the morning
and then executive session in the
afternoon
with one final executive session on may
18th i think
and representative horrigan do you have
a question
um well yes i was
just an observation which is um the
senate
has been meeting uh via zoom almost uh
every week
obviously they're a much smaller body
they're not much bigger than this
committee but we won't be meeting as the
full house until
june second and third i guess that's
still correct which means
even though we could form conference
committees if they actually revise this
bill instead of just sending it back to
committee so like uh
i guess we we i guess conference
committees can meet before june second
or third but we can't vote on the report
until the second and third or any
subsequent meeting until june is that
is that also uh that a
correct understanding of the situation
as far as anybody knows what's going on
with some i'm not sure if i do thanks
uh i don't think that we can have any
conference committees until after
uh we reconvene because there has to be
decisions made as to whether or not
we're going to
non-concur
concur or
non-concur and ask for a conference
committee
okay that would be that would be at our
session on the second and third i
believe
so follow-up so apparently i was
wrong so the recess
so that's not something we can do in the
recess from the past session which is to
non-concur and ask for a conference
committee so
i i don't believe that we can do that
okay thank you
representative simpson
thank you chair and gordon um i just
wanted to say that i asked ols for um
an amendment to part 11 of this omnibus
bill to take care of making the new
hampshire statute reflect what the
federal statute is about
licensing of industrial hemp growers so
i'll send that around to the committee
when i get that
and i know uh
as was indicated earlier that uh
representative burch
uh and i i have an amendment to i think
park is it part five
or of the bill
there were a number of amendments
mentioned here today and
i think senator carson mentioned an
amendment that we haven't seen yet which
may be forthcoming
i also i just want to note for the
record that uh after the committee uh
was convened this morning that we were
uh joined by uh representative
langley representative morgan
representative d lorenzo representative
smith and representative wolper so
and the record should reflect that
is there any other business today yeah i
would just note that the amendment
uh
that you just referenced that uh you and
i are
uh submitting i have mailed around and
you've had around to the committee
check your inboxes
okay
with that if there's nothing else we'll
adjourn and we'll see everybody next
week at nine o'clock
thank you bye thank you